Thank you.
So,
um,
I looked today and these lectures have
now been watched by,
they've been viewed a million times,
so that's pretty amazing.
Thank you.
Or they've been,
they've been glanced at a million times
that might,
that's also possible.
Alright.
So,
well let's get right into it.
So last week,
um,
I think was mostly remarkable for the
absolute dearth of content that was
actually biblically related.
So that was,
um,
I'm,
I'll just recap what I laid out so that
it sets the frame properly for what
we're going to discuss tonight.
And I presented you with an elaborated
description of,
of this diagram essentially,
which I spent quite a lot of time
formulating for probably about 25 years
ago,
I guess,
which kind of accounts for its graphic
primitiveness I suppose.
Um,
I was really pushing the limits of my
four 86 computer to produce that I can
tell you.
So,
and it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a description representation of the
archetypical circumstances of life and,
and the archetypical circumstances are
the circumstances that are true under
all conditions for all time.
And so you can think about them as
descriptively characteristic of the
nature of human experience that's not
exactly the same as the nature of
reality,
but because you can,
you can divide reality into it's
subjective and objective elements and
there's utility in doing that,
but these sorts of representations don't
play that game that they consider human
experience as constant constituted
constitutive of reality,
and that's how we experienced it.
And so we'll just go with that.
The idea basically is that we always
exist inside a damaged structure and
that structure is partly biological and
it's.
It's partly socio-cultural.
It's partly what's been handed to us by
our,
by our ancestors,
both practically in terms of
infrastructure,
but also psychologically in terms of the
active learning content of our,
of our psyches,
and so that would include,
for example,
our ability to do utilize language and
the words that we use and the phrases
that we use and the mutual understanding
that we developed as a consequence of
interacting with each other.
Architecturally speaking,
that structure is always.
It's always dad didn't corrupt and the
reason it's dead is because it was made
by people who are dead and the reason
it's corrupt is because things fall
apart of their own accord and the fact
that people don't aim properly,
let's say speeds along that process of
degeneration.
And so what that means,
and I think this is something worth
knowing.
Maybe I'll try standing back here and
see if that problem goes away.
Um,
what that means is that young people
always have a reason to be upset and
cynical about the current state of
affairs and,
and it's that way forever.
And,
and so it's useful,
I think,
to consider such consideration search
such conceptualizations as the,
of the,
as the patriarchy in that light because
it's an archetypal truth that the social
structure is corrupt and incomplete.
And,
and what that means is that it's
something that you have to contend with
every moment.
It's some sense of your life.
It's a,
it's a permanent fact of existence.
And to be upset that
the
structure is social structures or even
the biological structures within which
we live are incomplete and imperfect,
is to not take that personally,
that that's the worst part of it,
to take that personnel personally is a
misreading of the existential condition
of humankind because it's always the
case that what you have been given and
what you live in is degenerate and
corrupt and in need of repair.
And it's easier just to accept that
because there's also a positive element
and the pause development as well.
You've been granted something rather
than nothing and maybe you haven't been
granted pure hell because especially in
a culture like ours where many things
actually functioned quite well.
So there's room for gratitude there.
Even if it's a broken machine,
it's not one that's completely
devastated and it's not absolutely hell
bent on at every second on your misery
and destruction.
And it easily could be because many
societies are like that.
And so the fact that we happen to live
in one that isn't corrupt beyond
imagining is something to be eternally
grateful for.
While.
So we live inside a damage structure and
we also bear responsibility for that
damage because we don't do everything we
can to constantly repair it.
And you might say,
well that's actually one of the
fundamental,
you know,
people say,
well,
what's the meaning of life?
What they really mean is what's the
positive meeting of light?
Because as we've already discussed,
the negative
meanings of life or more or less self
evident,
well,
the positive meaning of life is to be
found in noting the state of lack of
repair,
of the,
of the walled city that you inhabit,
and then sally being forced to do
something about that,
to repair the breaches and to fix up the
walls and to make the structure that you
inhabit as secure and as productive as
it possibly can be.
And
there's no shortage of opportunities to
do that.
You can do that in your own mind.
You can do that in your own room.
You can do that in your own household,
in your local community,
you.
And maybe if you get good at doing it at
all those levels,
then you can start to look beyond that.
And so there's challenges.
That's the thing that's kind of
interesting about this insufficient
structure is that it has a set of
challenges built into it because of its
insufficiency and perhaps even because
of its corrupt nature that calls forth
the potential response from you of
heroic adventure and the heroic
adventure is to man the barricades and
repair the city.
And you can always do that.
It doesn't matter what what your
personal circumstances are.
There's always something that isn't
right near you,
isn't correct,
isn't laid out properly,
that you could just fix if you want it
to.
And one of the things that we're going
to talk about tonight is the idea that
if you adopt the attitude,
an attitude that's like that,
that the rule that you should play is to
make things better wherever you are.
However you can.
That what would actually happen would be
that things would get better wherever
you are in all sorts of ways.
And that we've really,
as a species you might say,
or maybe even as singular individuals
we've,
we've explored that rarely.
It isn't something that's put forth as a
proposition that often.
And it's quite surprising to me and you
know,
I had an interesting experience the
other day I went to the Gig,
I go there because I have food allergies
and they're very careful with people who
have food allergies.
And the waiter took me to the table and
he said that he had been watching my
lectures and that's a very common
experience and he was happy about that
and he said that he'd had two promotions
out the keg in the last four months
because he'd been watching my lectures
and like I really found that in
affecting experience because,
you know,
you might say,
well,
he's working as a waiter at the keg and
there's nothing particularly heroic
about that.
And,
and I disagree with that actually
because I don't care where you're
located,
you can do a hell of a job.
And I mean that literally at whatever
job you have,
you can,
you can take whatever job you have and
you can make it a real nice little piece
of absolute misery.
Or you can do.
You can act like a civilized human
being.
And notice that no matter where you are,
there's a,
there's a richness and a complexity
that's completely inexhaustible,
right at hand,
and then you can take that seriously and
you can say,
well,
I happened to be a waiter at the keg and
perhaps that's not what I expected.
And,
and he's a young guy and perhaps that
isn't where I want to end up,
but it's not nothing,
it's a rich environment and I can make
it a lot better if I want to.
I can get along properly with my
coworkers and not gossip behind their
back and I can treat my customers
properly and if an opportunity comes my
way I can take it and I can see what
happens.
And so he said that's what he had
started doing and that things were
working out much better for him.
He was in a much better job than he was
three months ago in three months.
That's nothing,
right?
I mean that's a nice trajectory.
It's an uphill trajectory and that's
what you want really an uphill
trajectory is actually even better than
being somewhere good as far as I'm
concerned because one of the things that
really makes your life meaningful is the
clear realization that you're headed
somewhere better than you are now.
And then it's even better if you also
understand that there's a direct causal
relationship between the things that
you're doing and the steepness of that
inclined.
And so I get a lot of letters from
people like that and they're more,
most frequently young men,
although not always.
And they say,
well,
you know,
I've been listening to these lectures
and I decided that I'm going to try to
take responsibility for my life.
And so I'm,
I've started to stop doing all the
stupid things that I know that,
uh,
that are stupid that I know I shouldn't
be doing.
And I've started doing some of the
things that aren't stupid that I know I
should be doing,
which seems pretty obvious really if you
think about it.
But it obvious though it may be that
isn't necessarily what people do.
And then they write and say,
you can't believe what difference that
makes.
And they're thrilled about it.
And so I'm thrilled about it when I get
letters like that because I really don't
experience anything as better than a
letter like that or a message like that
because it's so good to see things that
aren't so good,
replaced by something better.
And I really do think it's an open
question.
I truly believe it's an open question.
To what degree we could make things
better if that's what we actually aimed
at doing.
You know,
in some of the stories that we've,
we've covered already that story of Cain
and Abel in particular is really an
analysis of that problem which is so
remarkable that it occurs so,
so early in this document.
It's such a,
such a foundational story.
And it basically says,
well,
there's two modes of being in the world,
right?
There's one where you adopt the
responsibility for living properly,
for being properly and you make the
sacrifices necessary for doing that.
And then everything will flourish
properly.
And the other one is a pathway of
resentment and bitterness and rejection
and murder.
And genocide,
and that just seems exactly right to me.
And so if the positive path beckons,
if you can actually see what it is,
if you can,
if you can lower yourself enough to see
what it is.
Young Carl young set,
once that modern people didn't see God
because they didn't look low enough.
So phrase I really,
really like because people denigrate the
opportunities that are right in front of
them and there's no reason to do that
because what's right in front of you is
the majesty of being.
That's what's right in front of you.
It's inexhaustibly complex and full of
potential.
And there's no reason to assume that
wherever you happen to be isn't as good
as starting place as anywhere else.
Now,
you know,
I know some people have terrible,
terrible lives.
They're in situations that are
absolutely unbearable and,
but I also do know that even situations
like that can be made a hell of a lot
worse by the bat,
by,
by the worst kind of attitude.
That's for sure.
So,
so anyways,
so that's where you are,
you're in a damaged structure,
you're a damaged structure,
but you know at least it's got some
walls,
you know you're not being fed to the
lions on a regular basis.
So that's a good thing and you can,
you can emerge forward,
know,
heroically,
magically to confront the chaos that
constantly threatens the structure
within which you live and you can free
something as a consequence of that.
You can learn something.
You can strengthen yourself.
That's the other thing,
because the way what you're actually
made of in many ways that what informs
you,
what you're made of is what you
encounter when you voluntarily encounter
the unknown.
And so the more you voluntarily
encountered the unknown,
the more you get made of and the more
you get made of the more there is to you
and then the more you're good at
encountering the unknown and
restructuring order and calling forth
proper order out of the potential of
being and God,
you got to think,
why wouldn't you do that?
Since you can do that,
and it's an endless mystery.
You know,
I think part of it is that people,
well,
it's also encapsulated to some degree in
the story of Adam and Eve because what
happens to Adam is when you become self
conscious,
right?
He,
he becomes ashamed of his self in
regards himself as a lowly sort of
creature and there's endless reasons why
people would do that because of course
were rife with imperfection and so he
hides from God.
And I think that's actually the answer
to the conundrum,
which is that people don't aspire to the
highest good because they're deeply
ashamed of themselves and their
weaknesses and their insufficiencies.
And so it's,
it's not the only reason.
I mean there's,
there's the desire to avoid
responsibility and there's all the
negative motivations as well,
like resentment and hatred and the
desire to make things worse.
I don't want to,
you know,
give us,
given us too much of a break,
but,
but it's something like that,
but it's okay to not be in a very good
place if what you're trying to do with
that not very good place is make it
better.
And one of the things I really have
learned as a clinical psychologist is
that you just cannot believe how
powerful incremental progress is you.
You can do the calculations like it's
like compound interest,
you know,
if you make your life a 10th of a
percent better a week,
man in two or three years,
you're,
you're in such a better place than you
were,
that it isn't even like the same domain.
And if you keep that up for 10 years or
20 years,
you know,
especially if you're young and you start
early,
you start to straighten yourself out
and,
and fix the things that you can fix.
You can transform your lives in ways
that are completely unimaginable.
And God only knows what the upper limit
of that is in terms of human
possibility.
Because we are amazing creatures,
you know,
when we really get our act together and
stopped running at 10 percent of our
capacity.
So,
so,
so that's what you do.
You've got,
you know,
the fact that things aren't exactly the
way they should be,
at least gives you something to do.
You know.
And that's,
that's and,
and,
and maybe something great to do because
there's no shortage of suffering and
trouble that besets the world that you
could conceivably ameliorate in some way
and the utility and meaning the utility
of that and the intrinsic meaning of
that is self evident.
So it also makes me curious about
nihilism,
for example,
in despair,
because I mean I understand those
emotions and understand them deeply and
the intellectual mindset that goes along
with it,
but they just see beside the point to me
in some sense,
because there are so many things that
need doing that all you really have to
do is open your eyes and look at them
and then decide that you're actually
going to do something about them.
And you might think,
well,
what's within my scope of,
of,
of influence is so trivial that it's not
worth doing.
It's like it won't stay trivial for long
if you do it not at all.
And I don't think it's trivial to begin
with.
I don't think that any.
I really don't believe that anything
done right is trivial.
And my experience in my life has been
that anything I actually did paid off it
did didn't pay off necessarily in the
way that I expected it to pay off.
That's a whole different story.
But if it was genuine commitment to do
something,
even if it went sideways and the outcome
was really something other than what I
expected,
the net consequence over time was
nothing but good.
So every new frontier that can be
conquered is an advance forward and
there's no shortage of frontier because
we're surrounded by the unknown.
We're surrounded by our own ignorance
and we can continually move into that
domain,
into the domain of chaos,
or we can restructure pathological order
and that's,
that's the secret to proper being.
And so then you encounter chaos.
That way you know,
and then you can regard yourself as the
sort of entity that despite its
insufficiency,
has the capability to conquer chaos.
Despite the danger of that.
That's the other thing,
because the fact that you're fragile is
actually a precondition for your
heroism.
Because if you weren't fragile,
then there'd be nothing heroic about
doing something difficult.
Right?
Because if you couldn't be hurt or
damaged or defeated or or end up in
failure,
then where's the.
Where's the moral courage in the
endeavor it had?
It has to be that the fragility is built
into the courage and so it's not a.
it's not a reason not to engage in it at
all and in fact quite the contrary and
so
well and so then you know what do you do
while you put the city back together and
maybe the way you want it so that it's
functional and efficient and beautiful
and so the people can flourish there and
and and flourish in a manner that makes
them,
that makes them what w?
W,
what would you say that makes them feel
that the unbearable catastrophe of being
is worth it for the experience.
That's what you're aiming at and it's
not an impossibility.
It's not an impossibility,
and then not only that,
not only do you repair the city when you
do that,
but you make yourself the sort of thing
that continually repairs the city and
that's even better.
That's the end goal because it's not the
repair of the city.
That's the goal.
It's the transformation of yourself into
the thing that continually repairs the
city and so there's just no reason for
that not to happen and the more it can
happen,
the better.
Well there's A.
There's an under current to this story
and that is also the story of the flood
and that's the fact that you know the
city that can become corrupt because
people don't engage in heroic endeavor
perhaps because they engage in precisely
the opposite of that,
which is outright destructive behavior
and this is also something that's worth
considering too because if you.
If you,
if you consider your your own manner of
being,
you know,
you can say things to people like tell,
tell the truth and be good.
And those are.
Those are cliches obviously and so they
lack power because they're cliches,
but you can take them apart and utilize
them in a manner that stops being a
cliche and you do that by being more
humble about them.
I would say because maybe you can't tell
the truth because you don't know what
the truth is.
But one thing you can do is you can
start saying things that you know to be
untrue,
and you might say,
well,
how do I know that they're untrue?
And the answer to that is,
well,
you need a whole philosophy of truth,
the elaboration of an entire philosophy
of truth to answer that question and so
we're not going to bother answering that
question because in some sense at the
moment,
it's beside the point that isn't the
issue.
The issue is there are times in your
life where you know that the thing that
you're saying is not true.
It's a deception.
It's a lie of some sort,
and you're using it to manipulate
yourself or another person or the world
and you're also possessed,
fully possessed of the idea that you can
get away with it.
And there's a satanic arrogance about
that.
If in fact that is the of arrogance
that's portrayed in the mythological
character of Satan.
Because Satan is precisely the archetype
of the element of the mind that believes
that it can twist and and banned the
structure reality without paying the
price for that.
And you can't imagine anything that's
more arrogant than not because really do
you really think that you can twist the
structure of a reality and that that's
going to work out for you without it
snapping back?
It's so obvious that that can't work,
that,
that everyone knows it,
but anyways,
back to the initial point is that you
know by,
by the rules of the game that you
yourself are playing,
that some of the Times you're violating
the rules of the game that you're
playing,
and the first issue with regards to say,
stating the truth or behaving in a
responsible manner would be merely
stopped cheating at whatever game it is
that you've chosen to play.
That's a good start and that'll
straightened.
That'll straighten out your life.
It'll start in the street and start to
straighten out your life.
And so well the flood.
What?
How does the flood tie into this?
Well,
you know,
we live in a corrupt structure were
corrupt as individuals.
We live in a corrupt structure and part
of that corruption has just
happenstance.
It's the way things fall apart.
But the other part of it is that not
only are we not aiming up,
we're actually aiming down and the flood
story is a warning and it's a very clear
warning,
and the warning is if you aim down
enough and then if enough of you aimed
down at the same time,
everything will degenerate into
something that's
indistinguishable from the chaos from
which things emerged at the beginning of
time.
It's something like that because the,
the,
the cosmos that's presented in in
mythological representations is chaos
versus order.
Right?
The order is on top,
you might say in the chaos is always
underneath and the chaos can break
through or the order can crumble and you
can fall into the chaos and that chaos
is intermingled,
intermingled potential,
and the way that you destroy the order
and let the chaos rise back up,
which,
which is exactly how it's portrayed in
the flood story,
is by
well,
by inhabiting the corpse of your father.
That's one mythological motif and
feeding on the remains and with no
gratitude and no attempt to replenish
what it is that you're taking from and
the warning and the flood story is don't
do that for very long because things
will happen that are so awful you cannot
possibly imagine it and that'll happen
to you personally and what happened to
your family and it'll happen to your
community and it's happened to people
over and over throughout history and
it's quite interesting.
You know it's very soon after the story
of Cain and Abel.
When you see evil enter the world in the
story of Adam and Eve,
along with self consciousness and evil,
there is the ability.
That's the knowledge of good and evil.
That's the ability to hurt other people,
self-consciously,
to know what you're doing,
and then of course instantly cane takes
that to the absolute extreme and he uses
that capacity to to destroy really what
he loves best.
He,
he gets as close as a human being can to
destroying the divine ideal because of
course his brother is able,
enabled,
is favored by God and and destroys them,
which cane tells God at the end of that
episode that his punishment is more than
he can bear,
and I think the reason for that is where
are you?
Once you destroy your own ideal,
what's left for you?
There's nowhere to go.
There's no op and when there's no APP,
there's a lot of down and you know
there's an idea that was put forth very
nicely in Milton's paradise lost when he
was describing from a psychological
perspective.
Essentially what hell is hell is your
inhale to the degree that you're distant
from the good,
that that might be a good way of
thinking about it,
and if you destroy your own ideal,
which you do with jealousy and
resentment and and the desire to pull
down people who you would like to be,
let's say,
then you end up in a situation that's
indistinguishable from hell and the way
the story,
the biblical story unfolds as well.
It's,
it's,
it's Cain and then it's the flood,
and so kane adopts this mode of being
that's antithetical to being itself,
at least a positive being itself.
He does it voluntarily.
He does it knowing full well what he's
doing and the net consequence of this
that as it ripples through the entire
social structure is that God stands back
and says,
this whole thing has got so bad.
The only thing we can do is wipe it to
the ground and that is.
That is no joke.
That's exactly how things work.
And one of the things that's
extraordinarily terrifying about that
sequence of stories,
and I believe this to be true.
I think I realized this independently of
any of the analysis that I was doing of
mythological stories because I looked at
what happened in places like the Soviet
Union and miles,
China and in Nazi Germany and the most
penetrating observers of those
societies.
The people who are most interested in
how it was that those absolute
catastrophes came about.
All said the same thing.
It was rooted in the degeneration of the
individuals who made up the society.
You know,
you hear well,
people will fault were following orders.
It's like no that that explanation
doesn't hold water or that you'd be
punished if you resisted.
While there was some truth in that,
but nowhere near as much as people might
think,
especially at the beginning of the
process more it was that people decided
each and every one of them to turn a
blind eye to the catastrophes and to
participate in the lies and that worked
the entire societies and they went,
as you know,
they,
they veered their way downward to
something as closely approximating hell
as you could hope to manage,
especially in places like Nazi Germany
and well in all three of those places
and in China and in the Soviet Union.
And so the thing that's so frightening
about one of the things that's so
frightening about the stories in genesis
is they say something very clear,
which is that your moral degeneration
contributes in no small way to the
degeneration of the entire cosmos and
you say,
well,
I would like my life to be meaningful.
People say that really?
Would you really?
You really would like your life to be
meaningful.
You think maybe people would trade a
little nihilism to not have to face that
realization,
and I think people do that all the time.
It's a terrible wait to to to realize,
but we are networked together in the
price of or let's say that's the
vulnerability that's associated with our
intense capacity to communicate and it
is certainly possible that the ripples
of our individual actions have
consequences that are far beyond the
limits of our immediate consciousness
and I also think people know that too.
They know that in the way that people
know things when they don't want to know
them,
which means they know them,
embodied,
they can feel them,
they can sense them.
They have an emotional response to them,
but there's no damn way they're going to
let them become articulate because they
don't want to know and when you're
feeling guilty and ashamed about the
things you've done or not done,
and I know that can get out of hand as
well.
It's often because there is a crooked
little part of you that's aiming at the
worst possible outcome.
You know,
one of the things you said about the
shadow,
you know,
that young's famous idea that everyone
has a dark side and that that dark side
needs to be incorporated and made
conscious.
Young said to the shadow of the human
being,
reaches all the way to hell,
and he actually,
that's the thing that's so interesting
about interesting about reading Carl
young is he actually means what he says.
It's not a metaphor.
It's like the part of you that's twisted
against being is aligned with the part
of the cosmos.
Let's say the conscious cosmos that's
aiming at making everything as terrible
as it can possibly be and you know,
it's a terrible shock to realize that.
It's partly why people don't realize
that it's something that people keep at
an arm's length.
It's,
it's the same as recognizing yourself as
a Nazi concentration gap camp guard,
which is a very useful exercise because
there's absolutely no reason why you
couldn't have been or still could be one
so.
And if you think otherwise,
then all the more reason for assuming
that you would be unable to resist the
temptation if it wasn't in fact offered
to you.
And if you don't think it's a
temptation,
then the then there's so much that you
don't know about human beings that
you're not even in the game.
Because if it wasn't a temptation,
then people bloody well wouldn't have
done it.
And plenty of people did it.
And it's no wonder.
So.
So things get serious in genesis very,
very rapidly.
And,
and the depth of the seriousness is
ultimate archetipal.
That's it.
It gets as serious as it can get.
The story of Noah and the flood opens in
a fragmentary manner.
And I believe that these passages are
part of a longer story,
that we only have bits and pieces of it.
And also one that's fragmented in its in
its.
It's parts of more than one story.
And it starts like this and it came to
pass.
When men began to multiply on the face
of the earth and daughters were born
unto them that the sons of God saw the
daughters of men,
that they were fair and they took them
wives of all which they chose.
Now there's an idea there.
There's two ways of looking at the past
and you can kind of see that in the
political landscape that we inhabit.
Now on the more conservative end of the
spectrum,
people regard the past as the land of
giants,
right?
They were the heroes of the past who
established the current conditions that
we exist and then the people on the left
are more concerned perhaps with the,
what would you call it,
with a lineage of corruption that's come
down through the centuries and both of
those perspectives are are are accurate.
You can say,
well,
there were there,
there were the great heroes of the past
who established our modes of being.
You can think of them as competent
beings if you want.
That's fine.
That's a perfectly reasonable way of
thinking about it and you can also think
of the of the accumulation of corruption
and evil that's come along the centuries
as well,
and so you see both of those reflected
in these initial few lines that the sons
of gods,
so those are the heroes.
So the daughters of men that they were
fair and they took them wives of all of
which they chose.
Then this statement comes in as somewhat
of a non sequitur and the Lord said,
my spirit shall not always strive with
man for that he is also flesh.
Yet his days shall be 120 years.
And I looked at a variety of
interpretations of that line because it
doesn't seem to follow so clearly from
the previous line and exactly what it
means isn't obvious,
but it seems to be.
The first line talks about the heroes of
the past and and this.
The second line says,
well,
wait a second.
There's something corrupt about the
human mode of being and one of the
consequences of that as far as God is
concerned,
is that there are conditions under which
the divine spirit will not strive with
man.
What?
What that means is there are conditions
under which let's say the.
I don't think there's any other way of
putting it is the divine impulse towards
the good will abandon you because of
things that you've done and then the
secondary consideration here is that
perhaps because of the disc degeneration
of people,
it's not so obvious here that our
lifespans are limited,
that the,
that the spirit that inhabits us will
only do so for a limited amount of time
and that's tangled in a strange way in
with the idea of human moral culpability
and that's posed against the notion of
the giants of the past.
And then it returns to the giant idea.
That narrative returns to the giant idea
and reads.
There were giants in the earth in those
days and also after that,
when the sons of men came in unto the
daughters of men and they bare children
to them.
The same became mighty men,
which were of old men of renown,
and that that's the end of that sequence
of fragments.
It's very broken,
but you can see a dual narrative
underneath it.
And,
and one of the narratives is that
there's the kind of corruption despite
the giant,
the nature of the giants of the past.
There's the kind of corruption lurking
that would cause God to withhold his
grace and allow men to deteriorate.
And,
and that sets the stage for Noah and the
flood.
And God saw that the wickedness of man
was great in the earth and that the,
and that every imagination of the
thoughts of his heart was only evil
continually.
You know,
one of the things I really didn't like
about going to church when I was a kid,
I went to a pretty moderate church.
It was the United Church,
which has hardly even become a church
now.
It's so moderate,
so to speak.
Um,
one of the things I didn't like was the
constant harping by the ministry on the
sinful nature of human beings like it.
It didn't speak to me properly,
partly because I really didn't
understand what it meant.
Um,
and partly because it seemed
well sort of,
what would you say was self-flagellating
in an an attractive way?
I don't know if there is an attractive
way to be self-flagellating,
but there was,
it was,
and there was something about it that
was also wrote and fake that I didn't
like,
but you know,
in later years I thought about that more
and I started to understand that there
was some real utility in asking people
to keep the evil that they're doing
clear and conscious in the forefront of
their imagination.
I think I mentioned to you guys last
week that this little episode from what
we know of Mesopotamian culture
surrounding the emperor,
the New Year's festival,
they would take the emperor outside of
the walled city and strip him of his
garb so that he was reduced to just an
ordinary man and then humiliate them
richly and then ask him how it was over
the last year that he wasn't a
spectacular embodiment of Marduk.
Marduk was the Mesopotamian daddy who
made order out of chaos essentially.
And the emperor was supposed to sit and
think,
okay,
well,
you know,
I'm emperor and everything.
I should be doing a good job.
Maybe I should even be doing a great job
and probably I'm coming up short and a
bunch of ways and that actually happens
to be important since I'm running the
entire show.
I should be very,
very cognizant of how I'm failing to
live up to the ideal.
And that is what that call that constant
clarion call that's degenerated,
I would say an institutional
Christianity.
That was actually the idea was,
look,
there's a bunch of ways that you're not
being everything you could be and it is
not supposed to be a to try to knock you
down.
Although maybe it's a whip to knock down
your pride.
The pride that stops you from being
aware of your insufficiencies.
It's more like a call to the opposite.
It's like,
well,
you should stop doing those things
because you could be so much more than
you are and that would be so much better
for you and everyone else.
That is just.
It's just not good that you continue
doing these things.
Continue Breaking your own rules,
let's say,
because we could certainly,
as I said,
we could start this game by assuming
that you should at least play the game
that you're playing straight and so,
and it is the case that if you watch
yourself,
it's a terrifying thing to do.
But if you watch yourself,
you'll see you lie a lot.
Like when I learned this to begin with,
I was in my twenties and I was.
I'm a smart person and I was very proud
of that because I was also a small
person.
I was moved ahead one year in school and
I was a small person
to begin with.
And so as a very small person in my
classes and also very mouthy,
which might not come as much of a
surprise and somewhat provocative.
And so you know,
and I got pushed around a fair bit
because pete,
everybody gets pushed around and my
weapon was to be mouthy and it was a
fairly effective weapon.
Although tended to backfire because,
you know,
if you're really effectively mouthy with
large,
obnoxious people,
then they tend to respond in a
relatively negative physical way.
And so that sort of thing was happening
to me a fair bit and but I was quite,
I was quite proud of the fact that I
was,
that I,
I was,
I had some intellectual power
and
darn it was then in my twenties when I
learned about some of the danger of that
because I started to read partly
Milton's paradise lost and I started to
understand the,
the danger of the intellect and the
danger of the intellect as far as I can
tell,
is that it tends towards pride and
arrogance and it also tends to fall in
love with its own productions.
And so that's actually Lucifer in,
in,
in paradise lost.
That's Lucifer.
Lucifer is the intellect that falls in
love with its own productions and then
assumes that there's nothing outside of
what it thinks.
That's the totalitarian mentality,
right?
It's like we have a total system and we
know how everything works and we're
gonna implement it and that'll bring
about heaven on earth.
Right?
That's that say that.
That's the totalitarian mindset and
that's associated with intellectual
arrogance and
another at the same time.
Another thing that was happening to me,
so I was noticing that I started to
understand what that meant and I also
started to understand that there was
more to life than the intellect,
much more because I smoked too much and
I drank too much and I weighed like 130
pounds.
I wasn't in good physical shape and like
I had a lot of things to do when I went
to graduate school to put myself
together and at the same time I was
trying to understand why things had gone
so crazily wrong with the world.
It's encapsulation in the cold and what
role I might be playing in that,
if any,
or what role any of us were playing in
that.
Um,
at the same time I was working at a
prison only a little bit.
I worked with this crazy psychologist.
Um,
he,
he used to put jokes on is multiple
choice tests.
Uh,
he was a really eccentric guy,
but I really liked his courses.
He and he,
he taught a course on creativity and he
was also a prison psychologist and he
was an eccentric guy and he for some
reason liked me and maybe because I was
eccentric to and he invited me to go out
to the Edmonton maximum security prison
with them a couple of times,
which I did.
And that was a very interesting
experience because I was trying to
figure out what role each individual's
behavior bore to the pathology of the
group with something like that.
And I went out there and I met a little
guy smaller than me.
I was a little bigger by then and he was
a pretty innocuous guy.
And uh,
what had happened was I was out in this
gymnasium,
it looks like a high school,
the prison,
which is really quite telling in my
estimation,
but,
and there were all these like monsters
in their weight weightlifting and like
they were monsters.
I remember one guy who was tattooed
everywhere and he had like a huge scar
running down the middle of his chest.
It looked like someone had to hit them
with an ax and you know,
and,
and I was in there and I had this Weird
Cape that I used to wear that I bought
and Portugal and some boots that went
along with it and yeah,
it was like an 1890 sherlock Holmes Cape
and it was really like,
it was from the eighties and nineties
because this little village was up on a
hill.
It was a walled city on a hill and they
sold these things and I don't think they
changed the style since 1890.
And so I thought they were really cool
and so I was wearing that,
which wasn't perhaps the most
conservative garb to dawn if you're
going to wear,
if you're going to go to a maximum
security prison.
So anyways,
I was in the gymnasium and the
psychologist,
the psychologist left and God only
knows.
I mean that's what he was like.
And all these guys came around.
All these guys came around me,
you know,
and they were offering to trade their
prison clothes for my cape and he was
like,
I was being made an offer.
I couldn't refuse,
you know,
and so I didn't,
I didn't really know what to do and then
this little guy said something like
that,
the psychologist sent me to come and
take you away or something like that.
And so I thought,
well better this little guy then all
these monsters.
So we went outside the gym through some
doors,
like school doors.
We had outside the gym into the exercise
yard I guess,
and we're wandering along and he was
talking to me and he seemed like a kind
of an innocuous guy.
And then the psychologist showed up at
the door and motioned us back and so,
which was kind of a relief.
And so I went into his office and he
said,
you know,
that guy that you walked out in the yard
with?
And I said,
yeah.
He said he,
uh,
he took two cops one night and he had
them kneel down and while they were
begging for their lives,
he shot them both in the back
they had.
And I thought,
hmm.
That's.
See,
the thing that was so interesting was
that he was so innocuous,
right?
Because what you'd hope is that someone
like that would be very much unlike you,
let's say,
and certainly wouldn't be like somewhat
innocuous that you'd met.
What you'd want is that the guy would be
like,
you know,
half world wolf and half vampire so you
could just tell right away that he was a
cold blooded killer.
But no,
he was this sort of ineffectual little
guy who was certainly not ineffectual if
you gave him a revolver and the upper
hand.
And so.
So that made me think that made me think
a lot about the relationship between
being innocuous and being dangerous.
And then another thing happened.
I met another guy out there and then a
week or two later I heard that he and a
friend of his head held another guy down
and pulverized his left leg with a lead
pipe,
like just
pulverized it.
And the reason for that was that they
thought that he was a snitch and maybe
he was.
And that that time I did something
different instead of being shocked and
horrified by that.
Although I certainly was.
I thought,
how in the world could you do that?
Because I didn't think I could do that,
hey,
I didn't think that.
I thought that there was a qualitative
distinction between me and those people
and so I spent about two weeks trying to
see if I could figure out under what
conditions I could do that,
like what kind of psychological
transformation I would have to undergo
to be able to do that.
And so that was a meditative exercise,
let's say,
and it only took about 10 days for me to
realize that not only could I do that,
that it would be a hell of a lot easier
than I thought it would be.
And that's sort of where that wall
between me and what you describe is the
shadow started to fall apart and that
also was very useful because I started
to wreck.
I started to treat myself as somewhat
different entity because I hadn't been
aware up to that point,
you know,
because I thought I was a good guy and
there's no reason for me to think that
because you're not a good guy unless you
really made a bloody effort to be a good
guy.
You're just not.
It's not easy and so you're probably a
moderately bad guy and that's a long
ways from being an absolutely horrible
guy,
but it's also a long ways from being a
good guy and so,
but I had a little more respect for
myself after that because I also
understood that there was a monstrous
element to the human psyche that re that
you needed to respect and that was part
of you that you should regard yourself
in some sense as a loaded weapon.
It's very useful around children to
regard yourself as a loaded weapon
because around children you are a loaded
weapon and the terrible experiences that
many children have with their parents
are testament to that.
Anyways,
about the same time,
I don't exactly how these things were
causally related.
I guess it was because I was trying to
figure out who I was and how that could
be fixed.
Something like that.
I started to pay very careful attention
to what I was saying.
I don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily,
but I could feel a sort of split
developing in my psyche and the split
and I've actually had students tell me
the same thing has happened to them
after they've listened to some of the
material that,
that I've been describing to all of you,
but split into two,
let's say.
And one part was the,
let's say the old me that was talking a
lot and that liked to argue and that
liked ideas and there was another part
that was watching that part,
like just with it's eyes open and
neutrally judging and the part that was
neutrally judging was watching the part
that was talking and going,
that isn't your idea.
You don't really believe that you don't
really know what you're talking about.
That isn't true.
And I thought,
hmm,
that's really interesting.
So now,
and that was happening to like 95
percent of what I was saying and so then
I didn't really know what to do.
I thought,
okay,
this is strange,
so maybe I've,
I've fragmented and that's just not a
good thing at all.
I mean,
it wasn't like it was hearing voices or
anything like that.
I mean,
it wasn't like that.
It was,
it was.
Well,
people have multiple parts,
so then I had a weird conundrum.
It's like,
well,
which of those two things are me?
Is it the part that's listening and
saying,
no,
that's rubbish.
That's a lie.
That's you're doing that to impress
people.
You're just trying to win the argument,
you know,
was that me or was the part that was
going about my normal verbal business?
Me and I didn't know,
but I decided I would go with the critic
and then what I tried to do,
what I learned to do I think was to stop
saying things that made me weak and now
that I mean I'm still trying to do that
because I'm always feeling when I talk,
whether or not the words that I'm saying
are either making me a align or making
me come apart,
and I think the alignment.
I really do think the alignment is.
I think alignment is the right way of
conceptualizing it because I think if
you say things that are as true as you
can say them,
let's say,
then they come up,
they come out of the depths inside of
you because we don't know where it
thoughts come from.
We don't know how far down into your
substructure.
The thoughts emerge.
We don't know what processes have
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak from the core of your
being.
We don't understand any of that.
We don't even conceptualize that,
but I believe that you can feel that and
I learned some of that from reading Carl
Rogers,
by the way,
who's a great clinician because he
talked about mental health in part as a
coherence between the,
the,
the spiritual or the or the abstract and
the physical that the two things were
aligned and,
and there's a lot of idea of alignment
in,
in psychoanalytic and clinical thinking.
But anyways,
I decided that I would start practicing
not saying things that would make me
weak.
And what happened was that I had to stop
saying almost everything that I was
sick.
I would say 95 percent of it as a hell
of a shock to wake up and mean.
This was over a few months,
but it's a hell of a shock to wake up
and realize that you're mostly dead
wood.
It's a shock,
you know,
and you might think,
well,
do you really want all of that to burn
off?
It's like,
well,
there's nothing left,
but a little husk,
five percent of you.
It's like,
well,
if that five percent is solid,
then maybe that's exactly what you want
to have happen.
Well,
so I told you that story is an
elaboration of this line,
and God saw that the wickedness of man
was great in the earth and that every
imagine have the imagination of the
thoughts of his heart was only evil
continually to question worth asking
just exactly what are your motives?
Well,
you know,
maybe they're purer than mine were and
it's certainly possible.
I don't think that I'm naturally a
particularly good person.
I think I have to work at it very,
very hard and I don't necessarily think
that everyone is like that,
but some people are worse than that.
And everyone's like that to some degree.
So it's worth thinking about just how
much trouble are you trying to cause,
you know,
and the other thing you might think
about is that if you're not doing
something important with your life by
your own definition,
because that's the game that we're
playing,
you get to define the terms at least
initially,
maybe you're prone to cause trouble just
because you don't have anything better
to do because at least it's trouble is
more interesting than boring.
You know,
that's something you learn if you read
Dostoevsky,
does Tsq knew that extraordinarily well?
And so if you're not doing something,
if you're not pushing yourself to the
limits of your capacity,
then you have plenty of leftover.
What would you say will power,
energy and resources to devote to
causing interesting trouble?
And so well.
So I would say this is also an
archetypal scenario.
God saw that the wickedness of man was
great in the earth and that every
imagination of the thoughts of his heart
was only evil continually.
That's something to meditate on and it's
not self destructive because what it is,
is an attempt to.
It's like the diagnosis of an illness.
It's like if that does happen to be the
case for you or to some degree,
maybe it's only 10 percent of you or
something,
or maybe it's 90 percent.
Well then coming to terms with that is
excellent because then maybe you can
start doing it and what would be the
downside to that?
You'd have to give up your resentment,
obviously in your hatred and all of
that,
and that's really annoying because those
emotions are very.
They're easy to engage in in there and
they're engaging and they have this
feeling of self righteousness with them
and that goes along with them,
but you're not doing this.
In order to put yourself down.
You're doing this in order to separate
the wheat from the chaff and to leave
everything that you don't have to be
behind,
and it repented the Lord that he had
made man on the earth and it grieved him
at his heart,
and the Lord said,
I will destroy man whom I've created
from the face of the earth,
both man and beast and the creeping
thing and the fowls of the air for
repentance.
Me That I've made them.
What's the idea?
Well,
the idea is that the cosmos that God
created has become corrupt,
and that's a funny thing because you
know this is the other thing about
genesis that always hits me,
is that that's also true.
I told you that the Mesopotamians
believed that human beings were made out
of the blood of king,
knew who was the worst monster monster.
That the dragon of chaos could imagine.
That's a pretty harsh diagnosis,
but,
but the reason the Mesopotamians
believed that is because they knew as
did the authors of Genesis,
that human beings are the only creatures
in the cosmos.
Let's say the cosmos of being who are
actually capable of deceit,
conscious deceit,
and malevolence,
and the question is,
to what degree does the expression of
that conscious deceit and malevolence
corrupt things so badly that it would be
better that they didn't exist at all?
Well,
you see stories.
There's a story associated with this in
the epic of Gilgamesh,
associated with the flood that has
exactly the same underlying narrative
structure.
In fact,
some people think the story of Noah was
derived from it,
where the gods who created repented of
their creation and determined that
erasing it would be better than allowing
it to propagate.
And you see the same thing in the
Mesopotamian creation myth.
Enuma elish because the early gods,
so they're representatives of,
of the giants of humanity,
I would say,
make so much noise and are so careless
that the original creator God timeout in
her concert time,
Matt decides to wipe them from the face
of the earth.
And so when you read something like
this,
if you read it from an informed
historical perspective,
it starts to have a depth that makes it
transcend the sort of archaic and fairy
tale like element of the story.
It's like I've read some very terrible
things about what happened in Nazi
Germany and what happened when the
Japanese invaded China and just what
happened generally in the history of
mankind.
Things can get so bad that it takes the
imagination of a very bad person to
conceptualize them and when they get
that bad,
this is the only kind of language that
works to describe them.
You know,
that's another thing that I've
discovered working with my clinical
clients is when their lives are really
not going well,
you know,
when they're close to suicide or when
they're close to homicide or when there
are things going on in the family that
are so corrupt and terrible that they
reached back generations and they're
aimed at nothing but misery and
destruction.
The only language that suffices has a
religious tone because there's nothing
else that's available to describe what's
happening with the proper level of
seriousness.
And it might be that you've never
encountered a situation that required
that level of seriousness,
but that doesn't mean that those
situations don't exist.
They exist.
You generally do everything you can to
avoid being ensconced in them,
but they certainly do exist in the
probability that you'll encounter a
situation like that.
Or two,
at some point in your life is
extraordinarily high.
You'll tangle with someone who's
malevolent right to the core,
and maybe it'll be you that is,
and that'll be a big shock.
And then these sorts of things,
these sorts of poetic descriptors start
to become much more real.
But Noah found grace in the eyes of the
Lord.
These are the generations of Noah.
Noah was a just man and perfect in his
generations.
And Noah walked with God.
That's an interesting line because if
you remember back in the story of Adam
and Eve,
what happens to Adam once he eats the
fruit of the tree,
of the knowledge of good and evil and
wakes up the scales fall from his eyes,
become self conscious,
develops the knowledge of good and evil
is he won't walk with God when God calls
him in the garden and so noah is Adam
without the fall essentially,
and there's something that Noah was
doing right that
motivates God to spare him or maybe to
show him a pathway through the emergent
chaos,
something like that,
and that's worth thinking about a lot
because there will be situations in your
life where what you face is the emergent
chaos and maybe that'll be some terrible
catastrophe inside your family or maybe
it'll be something that's occurring on a
much broader social level,
but the chaos is coming and what you're
going to want to know.
Unless you want to be a dentist and have
the chaos or even a contributor to it
and perhaps that is what you want.
Because many people under those
circumstances choose that.
What you want is to know how you build
an Ark and get through it.
That's what you.
If you're,
if you're interested in life,
if you're interested in proper being and
you're disinclined to produce any more
suffering,
the necessary,
then you want to know how to conduct
yourself when the catastrophe comes so
that you have a reasonable possibility
of of moving through it and starting a
new.
So when when this old story says,
well,
God's not happy and he's going to wipe
everything out.
It's like,
well,
you might want to take that seriously
and then when it says,
but there's one person who had a motive
being that protected him from that.
That's also something you might want to
take seriously because you might want to
know what that mode of being is because
you might need to use it,
and so these sorts of things are
practical in the deepest possible sense.
They're real in the deepest possible
sense and practical in the deepest
possible sense.
So Noah walked with God.
Now I'm going to switch way ahead here
because I said at the beginning of the
lecture series that the Bible is a
hyperlinked text and everything refers
to everything else and so there's
utility in reading it in linear order,
but it's not a linear document.
It's a document that
that you can move through in an infinite
number of.
There's an infinite number of pathways
that you can use to walk through it and
all of the document expands upon and
refers to all of the rest of the
document and so I'm going to search
switch to the sermon on the mount,
which I think is probably the key
document in the New Testament and I'm
going to switch to it because I think
it's the closest thing we have to a
fully articulated description of what it
would mean to walk with God so that
you're in the Ark.
When the flood comes.
It's the.
It's the most fully articulated
realization of that idea that that leaps
out of the metaphorical.
Because if I say,
well,
you should conduct yourself like,
no,
and walk with God and build an Ark.
Obviously those are poetic and
metaphorical suggestions and it's not
that easy to bring them into practice,
right?
It's the distance.
There's a big distance between you and
the archetype.
It isn't obvious how to manifest it in
your own life and what has to happen is
the archetype has to be differentiated
in articulated so that it becomes
sufficiently practical and personal so
that you can actually implement it.
So I'm going to take apart some of the
sermon on the mount.
It starts in Matthew five and I'm not
going to talk about Matthew Five.
I'm going to talk about the end of
Matthew six and most of matthew seven.
Consider the lilies of the field,
how they grow.
They toil.
Not Neither do they spin,
and yet I say unto you that even Solomon
in all his glory was not arrayed like
one of these.
Wherefore,
if God so clothes the grass of the
field,
which today is and tomorrow is cast into
the oven,
shall he not much more clothe you.
Oh Ye of little faith.
Therefore,
take no thought saying what shall we eat
or what shall we drink or wherewithal
shall we be closed?
Those are famous lines and that sort of
Christ the Hippie,
right?
It's like,
Hey,
let it all hang out.
It's an old phrase,
do your thing and everything will come
to you and these lines have been
interpreted in that manner many times,
but that's seriously not the proper
interpretation because there's a kicker
with this injunction and the kicker is
this,
for your heavenly father knows that you
have need of all these things,
but seek ye first the Kingdom of God and
his righteousness and all these things
shall be added unto you.
That's a lot different than the hippie
thing,
right?
Because there's a very,
very,
very interesting idea here.
It's,
it's certainly one of the most profound
ideas that I've ever encountered and the
idea is this,
is that if you configure your life so
that what you are genuinely doing is
aiming at the highest possible good,
then the things that you need to
to survive and to thrive on a day to day
basis will deliver themselves to you.
That's a hypothesis and it's not some
simple hypothesis,
right?
Because what it basically says is if you
dare to do the most difficult thing that
you can conceptualize,
your life will work out better than it
will.
If you do anything else.
Well,
how are you going to find out if that's
true?
Well,
it's a Kierkegaardian leap of faith.
There is no way you're gonna.
Find out whether or not that's true
unless you do it so no,
no one can tell you either because just
because it works for someone else.
I mean that's interesting and all that,
but it's no proof that it'll work for
you.
You have to be all in in this game,
and so the idea is seek ye first the
Kingdom of God and his righteousness.
It's like that's actually a fairly
important caution when you're talking
about not having to pay attention to
what you're going to eat or what you're
going to where it's like what it's
essentially saying is that those
problems are trivial in comparison and
the probability is that if you manifest
yourself properly in the world,
that those things will come your way is
extraordinarily high and I believe,
I believe that that's exactly right.
I mean,
I,
I've,
I've watched people operate in the world
and I would say that there is no more
effective way of operating in the world
then to conceptualize the highest good
that you can and then strive to attain
it.
There's no more practical pathway to the
kind of success that you could have if
you actually knew what success was.
And so that's what this,
that's what this sermon is attempting
to,
to pause it.
It's like in,
in the story of Pinocchio.
You know what happens at the beginning
of the story of Pinocchio is that Japan
auto wishes on a star.
We talked about that a little bit and so
what you pedal does is align himself
with the metaphorical manifestation,
the highest good he can conceptualize
and say,
he says he makes sure he makes a
commitment.
Let's say he aims at the star and for
him the star is the possibility that he
can take his creation,
a puppet whose strings are being pulled
by unseen forces and have it transform
into something that's our economists and
real.
Yeah,
well that's a hell of an ambition.
You know when we're wise enough to put
that into children's movie,
but too foolish to understand what it
means.
It's such an interesting juxtaposition
that that we can both know that and not
know it.
At the same time you can go to the
movie,
you can watch it and it makes sense,
but that doesn't mean that you can go
home and think,
well,
I know what that meant.
While people are complicated,
right?
We exist at different levels and all the
levels don't communicate with one
another,
but.
But the movie is a hypothesis and the
hypothesis is there's no better pathway
to self realization and the enablement
of being than to pause it.
The highest good that you can conceive
of and commit yourself to it.
And then you might also ask yourself,
and this is definitely worth asking,
is do you really have anything better to
do?
And if you don't,
well why would you do anything else?
Therefore take no thought for the
morrow,
for the moral shall take thought for the
things of itself sufficient unto the day
is the evil thereof.
I spend a long time trying to figure out
what that man to because it's another
one of those lines
can easily be read as pro grasshopper
and anti amped.
You know,
you remember the old fable of the
grasshopper and the end.
Maybe not,
I'm not going to tell it,
but that works.
And the grasshopper fiddles and the aunt
has a pretty good time in the winter and
the grasshopper dies.
And so this is like a pro grasshopper
line,
but it's not because it says something
else.
It says that if you orient yourself
properly
and then pay attention to what you do
every day that works and it.
I actually think that that's in
accordance with what with what we have
come to understand about human
perception because what happens is that
the world shifts itself around your aim
because you're.
You're a creature that has an aim.
You have to have an ame in order to do
something.
You're aiming creature.
You look at a point and you move towards
it.
It's built right into you and so you
have a name.
Well,
let's say your aim is the highest
possible ame.
Well then so that sets up the world
around you.
It,
it organizes all of your perceptions.
It organizes what you see and you don't
see.
It organizes your emotions and your
motivations.
So you organize yourself around that aim
and then what happens is the day
manifests itself as a set of challenges
and problems and if you solve them
properly,
then you stay on the pathway towards
that eighth and you can concentrate on
the,
on the,
on the day,
and so that way you get to have your
cake.
And eat it because you can,
you can point into the distance,
the far distance and you can live in the
day
and it seems to me that that's.
That makes every moment of the day
supercharged with meaning that that's
because if everything that you're doing
everyday is related to the highest
possible aim,
that you can conceptualize,
well,
that's the very definition of the
meaning that would sustain you in your
life well,
and then the issue is well back to Noah,
well all hell is about to break loose
and chaos is coming.
It's like when that's happening in your
life,
you might want to be doing something
that you regard as truly worthwhile
because that's what will keep you afloat
when,
when everything is flooded and you don't
want to wait until the flood comes to
start doing that.
Because if you're arcs half built and
you don't know how to captain it,
the probability is very high that that
you'll drown.
Take therefore no thought for the moral,
but for the morrow shall take thought
for the things of itself,
sufficient unto the day is the evil
thereof.
That's not a particularly optimistic
formulation,
judge,
not that you be not judged for with what
judgment you judge.
You shall be judged and with what
measure you meet.
It shall be measured to you.
Again,
to sensible piece of.
It's a sensible description.
I wouldn't call it a piece of advice
because I don't think that any of this
is advice.
It's a description of the structure of
reality that's not the same as advice
and it basically says that you'll be
held accountable by the rules of the
game that you choose to play
and that I also think is perfectly in
keeping with what we understand about
human psychology because you you are
playing.
You have to play a game that other
people will allow you to play and that
will cooperate with you while you're
playing and that will compete with you
while you're playing it,
but you have a fair bit of flexibility
in setting up the parameters of the
game,
but you don't have any choice about
whether or not you're going to be in a
game.
You're in a game and you're going to be
held accountable by the rules of the
game because that's how the game works
and so you might want to pick a game by
whose rules you would be willing to be
held accountable and why be hold us Dow,
the moat that isn't my brother's eye,
but consider it's not the beam that is
in dire or how will you say to that,
I brother,
let me pull out the motive out of the
Nih and behold,
a beam is in nine Onei.
What you might be wondering,
what a b medicine,
a moat is,
the dust speck and a beam is a very
large piece of lumber and so the issue
is
not so much the blindness of others even
though there's as much blindness among
others as there is as there is for you.
But the issue here,
the advice here,
the description here is you should be
concerned about what's interfering with
your own vision first and you should
leave other people.
The hell alone in relationship to that.
And so if you're a mode of being in the
world is if you would just act better,
things would improve for me.
Or if you identify the evil and the
catastrophe is something that's outside
that someone else needs to fix or that
someone's responded to someone else's
responsible for,
then then you're not going to fix that
and you're going to remain blind to the
things that you're doing and not doing
that make things not go well.
And so it's just better to think,
all right,
I'm probably blind in many,
many ways and maybe there are some ways
that I could rectify that because it's
highly probable that you're blind and
all sorts of ways.
I mean it's,
it's in fact it's virtually certain and
so it's just more useful to think,
how is it that I'm wrong in this
situation?
I'll tell you something that I learned
to do when I was arguing with my wife,
which happened quite frequently.
Because when you actually communicate
with people,
you find out that there's many things
that you don't agree on and that's
because you are actually different
creatures.
And so if you're actually going to have
a truthful conversation,
then you're going to find out that you
don't see things the same way and then
you can either pretend that that's not
the case in gloss over it and then ended
up in a 30 year silent war or you can or
you can have the damn fight when you
need to have it and see if you can
straighten it out.
So now and then we'd get into a
situation where we were at loggerheads,
we couldn't move and it would spiral up
into hate speech,
let's say,
because yeah,
everyone laughs because they know they
manifest plenty of hate speech towards
those they love.
So one of the things we learned to do
was when we hit an impasse was to
separate and to go our own ways and to
go sit and think,
okay,
look,
we're at this
unpleasant situation.
We can't figure out how to move forward.
I'd always think,
of course it's her fault.
Obviously it's her fault.
Least Ninety five percent.
But maybe there was something I did that
contributed like five percent to it.
And so I would sit and think and ask
myself a question,
which was,
is there anything I did in the last six
months that increase the probability
that this impasse would manifest itself?
And I'll tell you,
you have no idea how fast your mind will
generate an answer to a question like
that because there's undoubtedly some
idiotic thing that you did that you
know,
that you remember,
that increased the probability that
you're going to have your hands around
the throat of the person that you love.
And then you can go tell them that and
then you can have a conversation,
especially if they do the same thing.
Say,
look,
you know,
here's how I'm an idiot in this
situation.
Now there person says,
well,
yeah,
it's,
here's how I'm an idiot,
and then your two idiots and then maybe
you can have a conversation.
So thou hypocrite first cast out the
beam of light out of I know,
and I,
and then shalt thou see clearly to cast
out the mote of my brothers.
I,
that's pay hard to argue with that ask.
And it shall be given you.
Seek and Ye shall find knock and it
shall be opened unto you for everyone
that Asketh receive it and he that
seeketh findeth and to him that hath it
shall be opened.
That sounded pretty optimistic again,
but,
but again,
I think it's a description of the
structure of existential reality and and
by,
by which I mean
when I'm in my clinical practice and I
observe and this is also the case with
my students,
is let's say people's lives aren't what
they would like them to be.
And so then you ask why?
Well,
forget about tragedy and catastrophe
because that's self evident and we're
not gonna discuss that.
Although the degree to which you bring
about your own tragedy is always
indeterminant,
but I would never say that every
terrible thing that is visited on a
person is something they deserved.
I think that that's a very dangerous
presupposition,
especially because everyone gets sick
and everyone dies,
but one of the main reasons that people
don't get what they want is because they
don't actually figure out what it is and
the probability that you're going to
get.
What would be good for you.
Let's say,
which would even be better than what you
want,
right?
Because you know,
you might be wrong about what you want
easily,
but maybe you could get.
What would really be good for you?
Well,
why don't you.
because you don't try.
You don't think,
okay,
here's what I would like if I could have
it and I don't mean I don't mean in a
way that you manipulate the world to
force it to deliver you good for status
or something like that.
That isn't what I mean.
I mean something like imagine that you
were taking care of yourself like you
were someone you actually cared for and
then you thought,
okay,
I am caring for this person.
I would like things to go as well for
them as possible.
What would their life have to be like in
order for that to be the case where
people don't do that?
They don't sit down and think,
all right,
know,
let's,
let's figure it out.
You're,
you've got a life.
It's hard.
Obviously.
It's like three years from now you can
have what you need.
You got to be careful about it.
You can't have everything you can have,
what would be good for you,
but you have to figure out what it is
and then you have to aim at it.
Well,
my experience with people as being as if
they figure out what it is that would be
good for them and then they aim at it,
then they get it and it's strange
because they don't know.
It's a strange thing.
It's not quite that simple because you
know you may formulate an idea about
what would be good for you and then you
take 10 steps towards that and you find
out that your formulation was a bit off
and so you have to reformulate your
goal.
So you're kind of going like this as you
move towards the goal.
But a huge part of the reason that
people fail is because they don't ever
set up the criteria for success.
And so since success is a very narrow
line in very unlikely,
the probability that you're going to
stumble on it randomly is zero.
And so if there's a proposition here in
the proposition is if you actually want
something,
you can have it.
Now the question then would be,
well,
what do you mean by actually want?
And the answer is that you reorient your
life in every possible way to make the
probability that that will occur as
certain as possible and that's a
sacrificial idea,
right?
It's like you don't get everything.
Obviously you obviously,
but maybe you can have what you need and
maybe all you have to do to get it is
ask,
but asking isn't a whim or today's wish.
It's like you have to be deadly serious
about it.
You have to think,
okay,
like I'm taking stock of myself and if I
was going to live properly in the world
and I was going to set myself up such
that being would justify itself in my
estimation,
and I don't mean as a harsh judge
exactly what is it that I would aim at?
Well,
one of the things I've found is that in
test of this theory,
let's say you can try this.
This is a form of prayer knocking.
Sit on your bed one day and ask
yourself,
what's what remarkably stupid things am
I doing on a regular basis to absolutely
screw up my life,
and if you actually asked that question,
but you have to want to know the answer,
right,
because that's actually what asking the
question means.
It doesn't mean just mouthing the words.
It means you have to decide that you
want to know.
You'll figure that out so fast.
It'll make your hair curl.
It's as if young thought about this,
he saw it.
He thought that people had two poles of
consciousness in one was the individual
consciousness that we each identify
within.
The other was something he called the
self and the self is the.
You might think about it as the divine
within.
That's close enough approximation.
It's the universal part of your
consciousness.
It's your conscience.
That's another way of thinking about it.
Whatever your conscience is,
but it's something that you can consult.
It's like the Socratic Damon.
Socrates said that the thing that made
him different than everyone else in
Greece was that he consulted his demon,
his genius.
He asked himself how it was that he
should conduct himself in the world,
and then he did that,
whatever it was,
he didn't try to force a solution.
You know,
Selfishly,
he asked,
I'm going to manifest myself in the best
possible manner in the world.
I would like to do that.
What would that be?
While you're perfectly capable of
thinking,
God only knows how you're perfectly
capable of immense feats of imagination
and dreams and fantasies.
God only knows how you do all of that.
What would happen if you consulted
yourself about the best possible outcome
for you?
You might get an answer,
well,
that's what this proposition is
have or what man is the review.
Who if his son asks for bread,
will give him a stone or if he asks for
a fish,
will give him a serpent if he then being
evil,
know how to give good gifts unto your
children.
How much more shall your father,
which is in heaven,
give good things to them that ask him,
well,
this is a question about the fundamental
nature of being,
I suppose and one of the hypotheses in
the new testament which is different.
It's a different hypothesis in some
sense than the one that structures the
old testament is that faith bakes being
good.
It's a very interesting proposition and
so the notion would be,
and it it's an action oriented issue as
well.
You act out the proposition that if you
act properly in the world,
that being will reveal itself to you as
benevolent,
but you will not know.
You'll never know unless you do it.
So this is a call to that.
Act out the proposition that if you act
properly,
that being itself is benevolent.
There's no reason to assume the
contrary.
I mean to assume the contrary.
It would be to be as cynical and bitter
as possible and it's not like we don't
have reason for that.
It's not like I don't understand why
that happens to people.
Therefore all things whatsoever you
would that men should do to you.
Do you even,
so to them for this as the law and the
prophets and that's a reciprocity issue,
right?
It's like while imagine what would be.
This is another thing I learned from
young because young reverse this because
this is often read,
it's the golden rule.
It's often read is be nice to be nice to
other people.
It's like that is not what this rule
means.
It doesn't mean that even a little bit
it means something like and we'll
reverse it so that will concentrate on
you rather than the other person to
begin with.
It means something like conceptualize
how things could be great if they were
great for you,
if you were taking care of yourself and
then work to make that the case for
everyone else.
You know?
You see that in Buddhism because Buddha
reached Nirvana,
right?
That's the theory and then he.
He was tempted with offer to stay there
and he rejected that offer and came back
to the profane world because he felt
that the attainment of nirvana was
insufficient unless everyone attained it
simultaneously and so it's something
like that,
but it's treat yourself properly.
That's a hard thing to do because you're
a fallen,
shameful,
cowardly,
deceitful,
malevolent,
mortal creature,
and so it's not easy and you know it and
it's not easy to treat something like
that properly and and,
and it isn't obvious that people treat
themselves better than they treat other
people.
I don't think that's obvious at all,
but maybe you could start with yourself
and think,
okay,
I'm going to take care of myself as if I
have value.
What would that look like and then I'm
going to work to extend that courtesy to
everyone else.
And that's.
Well,
the hypothesis here is that if you take
all of the moral wisdom that mankind has
generated over,
it's millennia of struggle,
evolved and then manifested metaphor,
story and then codified into law,
articulated law,
and you pick one principle that
dominated all of that.
This would be the principal
and it's interesting too because it's
the law and the prophets and the law is
the rules,
but the prophets or the process by which
the rules are being updated,
right?
So the profits are a superordinate in
some sense to the law and the
proposition that set forth in this
particular statement is that this maxim
which is optimize your own mode of being
and then work to do the same for
everyone around you,
is not only the thing that's at the core
of the law,
but it's at the core of the process that
generates it updates the law
to hell of a thing for someone to say,
enter ye in at the narrow gate,
because that's what straight means.
Enter ye in at the straight gate for
wide is the gate and broad is the way
that leads to destruction.
Well,
who in the world could possibly argue
with that?
Every one in their right mind knows that
there's a million ways of doing things
wrong and one way if you're lucky to do
things right,
and so the notion that it's a very,
very narrow pathway that you tread upon
if you're doing things right.
That's,
that's wisdom.
That's the line between chaos and order
that you're supposed to be on
constantly,
right?
It's a very,
very thin line because if you're a
little bit too far in one direction,
then it's too much chaos and if you're a
little too far in the other direction
that it's too much order and both of
those aren't good,
it has the balance,
has to be exactly right and you can feel
that and I truly believe you can feel
that and I think it's your deepest
instinct.
It's your deepest instinct that I mean
that.
I mean that biologically.
I don't mean that metaphorically.
I think that your psyche is arranged to
exist in a cosmos that's composed of
chaos and order.
I think that's why you have the
hemispheric structure that you have
this.
This is deeper than metaphor and then
when you feel as if you're meaningfully
engaged in the world,
when the terror of your mortality strips
away and you're engaged and it's
timeless,
that's the deepest instinct you have
telling you that you're in the right
place at the right time and then what
you do is practice being their practice
being there and that's that.
That narrow spot that's so difficult to
find.
You wander around it,
maybe if you're lucky,
you can watch,
you can watch.
This is an experiment.
Watch yourself for two weeks like you
don't know who you are because you
don't.
So watch yourself for two weeks and
notice there's gonna be times when
things are proper there,
raid properly for you.
It's not easy to notice because when
they're arrayed like that,
you're so engaged.
You don't exactly notice,
you know,
but you'll see,
oh,
I'm in the right place.
It's like,
okay,
how'd I get here?
What am I doing right?
You know,
how is it that this could happen more
often?
I'd like this to happen more often.
How would I have to conduct myself in
order for that to happen more often,
and then you practice that and then
maybe instead of 10 minutes a month or
10 minutes a week,
it's like 15 minutes a day and then it's
half an hour a day and then it's an hour
a day and then it's four hours a day and
maybe if you're.
If you're extraordinarily careful,
then you get to a point where you're
like that a good proportion of the time,
because straight is the gate and narrow
is the way which leadeth unto life and
few there be that find it.
You were a false prophets which come to
you in sheep's clothing,
but inwardly they are ravening wolves.
That's particularly good advice for
today's political situation.
I can tell you,
you shall know them by their fruits.
Do men gather grapes,
have thorns or figs of thistles even so
every good tree bringeth forth good
fruit,
but a corrupt tree bring forth evil
fruit?
Well,
that's what I learned from studying the
history of totalitarianism in the 20th
century is that a corrupt tree brings
forth evil fruit and that's for sure.
It's so funny.
You know people who think when they're
thinking about the relationship with
divinity or their relationship with God,
they think it's a primitive and childish
way of thinking.
What if a miracle just manifest?
Why kind a miracle just manifest itself
and I would be convinced,
and the funny thing is,
is first of all actually you wouldn't be
if a miracle actually happened,
you would actually forget about it and
about six months,
that's I mean you'd think that's not
true,
but it's true.
You would actually forget about it
because that's what people are like,
but there are negative miracles that are
happening all the time which actually
lend some credence to my supposition and
we don't pay any attention to that.
If we can't learn from what happened in
the 20th century,
then we are absolutely incapable of
learning because what in the 20th
century was as bitter a set of lessons
as you could possibly imagine,
and it's associated precisely with this.
A corrupt tree bringeth forth evil
fruit.
A good tree cannot bring forth evil
Neither can a corrupt tree bring forth
good fruit.
Every tree that bringeth forth that
bringith not forth good fruit is hewn
down and cast into the fire will.
That's a flood motif right there.
It's like we're constantly the archetype
of the tree.
That's the archetype of being the
architect.
Of the self often,
what's the warning here is that if
you're mostly dead wood,
you're going to get,
you're going to burn up and you can
think about that metaphysical.
You can.
You can project that into eternity and
you can think about that as a form of
hell.
And the funny thing is is that when
that's happening to you in real time,
it is like an eternity in hell.
It's a perfectly reasonable way of
thinking about it,
but you can strip the metaphysical
elements off and you can say,
well,
if you're mostly dead wood,
then a spark will light you on fire,
and that's also very much worth thinking
about.
Wherefore by their fruits shall you know
them.
Not everyone that say a fun to me,
Lord shall enter the Kingdom of Heaven,
but he that doeth the will of my father,
which is in heaven.
That's an interesting line.
I think.
I mean one of the proper critiques of
Traditional Christianity.
Maybe this is the sort of critique that
needs you to put forth was that
Christianity had degenerated and its
moral mission.
Young was a little bit more sympathetic
and I'll tell you why in a minute,
but niches idea was that Christianity
had lost its way when it generated the
presupposition that humanity was saved
in some final sense by the sacrifice of
Christ.
It meant that the work was already done
and that,
and I'm,
I'm being.
I'm being harsh in my judgment for the
purpose of rhetorical simplification,
but the idea was that if you just
professed faith that that had already
occurred,
then you were granted eternal salvation.
It's like,
well,
it's not so straightforward and I think
that that's what this line actually
represents.
It says,
how do you enter into the Kingdom of
Heaven?
And again,
you can think about that under the
aspect of eternity or you can think
about it as a psychological statement
and the answer is quite straightforward,
is that
you
do what Noah did to make him immune from
the flood and that's to walk with God
and that's what this sermon is about.
It's laying out the practical elements
of that and the practical elements are
aim at the highest possible.
Good and play that out in the world.
And then
you may have the opportunity to inhabit
the highest possible good that you're
positing into existence.
Perhaps not,
but you can't think of any more
practical way of going about that.
I mean,
if you build a house that maybe you can
live in it,
if you don't build a house,
you're not going to be able to live in
it.
If you build a good house,
then you'll be able to live in a house.
And if you build a perfect house,
then maybe you can live in a perfect
house.
But if you just say that the house has
already been built for you and that you
can just say that the house is being
built for you,
well then the probability that you're
going to be able to live where you need
to live is there's no probability that
you're going to be able to live where
you need to live.
Many will say to me in that day,
that's the judgment day.
Lord,
have we not prophesied in thy name and
the name,
have cast out devils in the [inaudible]
name,
done many wonderful works.
And then I will profess unto them,
I never knew you,
depart from me,
you that work iniquity.
See,
that's judgment day.
You know?
That's an archetypal idea and partly
it's archetipal because everyday is
judgment day and the part of you that
the part of you that's equivalent to the
logo,
say the part of you,
that's your own ideal,
sits in eternal judgment on your
inequity,
and that's the con.
That's the source of guilt and shame and
and and withdrawal and then resentment
and then murderousness and then
genocide.
It's because you can intuit the ideal
and the problem with intuiting,
the ideal is that an ideal is always a
judge.
There are no difference between an ideal
and the judge and so you're eternally
judged by your own ideal.
If you have no idea,
well then you've got no direction and no
meaning in your life.
And then of course the more extreme,
the ideal,
the harsher the judge.
That's actually why young young was very
curious about why the book of revelation
was tacked onto the Bible because the
book of revelation,
that's a very weird book and you know in
in,
in the Gospels,
Christ is I would say perhaps primarily
merciful.
There,
there's a maybe a war in his character
between truth and mercy,
but it's one of the two perhaps mercy
and Young's observation was the gospel.
Christ was to merciful and that's why
the book of revelation was tapped on,
tacked onto the new testament because in
the book of revelation,
Christ,
who's the ideal,
who's above the pyramid,
right?
The transcendent ideal is nothing but a
judge and everyone fails,
and of course the ultimate ideal is the
ultimate judge.
And so that's the archetypal reality
there.
And you can say,
well,
I don't want to be judged and so I'll
dispense with the ideal,
but then your cane,
because cane is exactly the person who
dispenses with the ideal.
And so there's no escaping from it.
There's no escaping from eternal
judgment.
That's the archetypal story.
You know,
people put a lot of work into these
representations,
you know,
and there's thousands of them.
They weren't messing around.
These are serious pieces of work,
you know,
we don't understand them,
but that doesn't mean that the people
who created them didn't know what they
were doing.
These were geniuses who created these
pieces of work.
It's not like they understood in an
articulated manner exactly what they
were trying to represent,
but what they were representing,
where the metaphor is at the core of our
culture,
to the degree that our culture is
functional and good.
These are the metaphors upon which it's
founded and they're not for the faint of
heart.
You know,
you say religion is the opiate of the
masses.
It's like,
yeah.
Then how do you explain this exactly.
You know,
because if it was opiates hereafter,
you might just get rid of that panel.
Especially when.
The other thing that's so interesting
about the proposition,
if you look at revelations,
revelation,
and you look at the judgment,
almost everyone ends up on the right
side of this panel.
So if you were just conjuring up some
sort of pathetic wish fulfillment,
why in the world would you tilt the
scales in that manner you think that's
supposed to make people feel good?
I don't think so.
There's almost nothing about this
picture that should make people feel
good.
It should if you understand it properly,
it should terrify you to the depths of
your soul.
That's what the picture is for.
Therefore,
whoever hears these sayings of mine and
do with them,
I will liken him unto a wise man which
built his house upon a rock and the rain
descended and the winds blew and the
floods came and beat upon the house and
it fell not for it was founded upon a
rock and everyone that hears these
sayings of mine and do with them not,
she'll be likened unto a foolish man
which built his house upon the sand and
the rain descended and the floods came
and the winds blew and beat upon that
house and it,
oh,
I made a mistake and it fell for.
It was founded upon the sand and it came
to pass.
This is a very interesting line.
I really,
I really know now,
and then you run across lines in this
particularly happens in biblical
settings.
You run across lines that you cannot
believe actually exists.
You cannot imagine how someone could
have imagined up and conjured up the
line and and these two lines are like
that as far as I'm concerned.
And it came to pass when Jesus had ended
these sayings that people were
astonished at his doctrine for he taught
them as one having authority and not as
the scribes.
And that's something so interesting
because that was another thing that
really I didn't really appreciate about
the churches that I attended to and that
would be that the lessons were taught by
scribes and the words were mouthed,
but there was no power in them.
There was no meaning in them.
It was,
it was as if,
well,
it was like when I was 20 years old and
I was saying all these things,
I didn't mean,
you know,
they were words that sounded good.
They were like,
like gilded cloth,
I suppose that you can that you can wrap
around yourself,
but there no substance to them and
there's a big difference between
listening to something that has
substance and listening to something
that is spoken because it sounds like it
should sound good and this line says
that whoever spoke the lines that we
just described was someone who sounded
like he knew what he was talking about
and not someone who is just repeating
something for the sake of sounding good,
and it certainly seems to me that the
lines that we just reviewed have the
awesome impact of authority
act to noah,
but Noah found grace in the eyes of the
Lord.
These are the generations of Noah.
Noah was a just man and perfect in his
generations.
Noah walked with God,
and Noah begat three sons,
Shem,
Ham,
and Japheth.
The Earth was also corrupt before God
and the earth was full of violence,
filled with violence.
Any of you see the new NRA ad?
You might want to look that up.
I would say that's the most shocking
manifestation of political polarization
in the United States that I've yet seen.
Most of it I've seen on the left,
the real.
What's shocked me mostly has been on the
left,
but the new NRA ad,
that's a whole new thing.
So it's this attractive woman doing a
voiceover.
She kind of looks like Demi Moore,
although she's Kinda tough looking.
I guess Demi Moore could look tough now
and then and she has contempt on her
face and that's a dangerous thing and in
the background there's nothing but
images of antifa riots and Berkeley
riots and fire and protest and she's
describing that is a conspiracy,
essentially a conspiracy that involves
the intellectual elite including
Hollywood,
which is named by name.
The accusation is that there is a cabal
of
corrupt intellectuals,
let's say,
who are bringing the country to its
knees and that it's time to get your God
damn guns and so look up that and see
what you think because
there's lots of people who would be
perfectly happy if that was the
direction in which we're headed.
And one of the things that I'm hoping is
that we might be able to talk our way
through it,
but we're in a situation where every act
of interview,
individual idiocy will push us one iota
closer to the break and that'll make the
15 of the population or 30 percent of
the population who would love to see
everything degenerated into chaos,
perfectly happy because that's their
aim.
Theory.
Salsa was corrupt before God and the
earth was filled with violence and God
looked upon the earth.
And behold it was corrupt for all flesh
is corrupted his way upon the earth.
And Noah said,
and God said unto Noah,
the end of all flesh has come before me.
For the earth is filled with violence
through them.
And behold,
I will destroy them with the earth.
Make the an ark of gopher wood rooms
shalt thou make in the arch,
and then pitch it within and without
with pitch.
And this is the fashion which thou shalt
make of it.
The length of the Ark,
shelby,
300 cubits,
the breadth of it.
50 cubits and the height of it.
30 cubits and window shelf.
They'll make to the arc in a cubit,
shelldale finishing above and the door
and the art shelters set in the side
there or with lower second and third
stories shall make it,
and behold,
I even I do bring a flood of waters upon
the earth to destroy all flesh wherein
is the breath of life from under heaven.
Everything that is in the earth shall
die,
but with the I will establish my
covenant and now she'll come into the
Ark,
thou and thy sons and a wife and they
sons wives with the.
That's a fairly optimistic twist on the
story because not only is it noah,
but he gets to save his whole family and
down a couple of generations and so
that's a good thing to think about.
It's like as things you know,
I had this client and she had a very
hard upbringing.
I would say.
Not a lot of encouragement to say the
least.
Let's say a fair bit of discouragement
and she had a son.
And what was really interesting about
her in relationship to her son is that
all the things that she could have
learned to do to him,
given her extensive experience with
being made as miserable as possible by
someone who was hell bent on bringing
her to her knees,
she refused to do,
to respond,
right?
She learned the opposite lesson from all
her misery and tournament,
which was not to move that forward down
the generations.
And so the idea here is that if you walk
properly and aimed properly and act
properly,
if you walk with God in this manner that
we've been discussing,
is that perhaps that isn't only good for
you,
perhaps it's also the thing that will
save your family and then by implication
perhaps save society because that's
exactly what happens with Noah,
right?
First attempt and then it's his family,
but everything else goes.
And so by saving himself,
by acting properly and by saving his
family,
he actually saves the world.
It's interesting,
you know,
like the most profound people that I've
read who've meditated deeply on the
problem,
say of totalitarian catastrophe.
And I would put Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn
at the top of that list,
you know,
hit the his,
his entire Corpus,
three volume 700 pages long.
Each in tiny type is a long scream about
the absolute necessity of individual,
the absolute necessity of individual
honesty and ethical behavior as the only
bulwark against totalitarian
catastrophe.
And the.
And I've read many writers who've
attempted to diagnose the problems of
the 20th century and I think units.
And
he came to the same conclusions that
Victor Frankel came to as a consequence
of his experiences in the Nazi
concentration camps and Frankel.
I'm also an admirer of Frankl,
but soldier knits and takes it to an
entire different level of profundity and
makes an extraordinarily strong case
that not only do societies deteriorate
because the people within the societies
become individually corrupt,
but that the only way to stave that off
is for the individuals within that
society to reject that corruption in
the,
in the confines of their own personal
lives.
And he tells endless stories of people
that he met in the Gulag,
in the work camps,
in the death camps,
in the Soviet Union of people.
And this is what he learned.
If people who are so incredibly tough
that even under conditions the most
possible extreme conditions,
there wasn't a chance that they were
going to step off that straight narrow
line.
There was nothing the authorities could
do to move them and just watching that
was enough to transform soldier knits
and because of course one of the things
he wondered was after spending a good
amount of time in the work camps was
well just exactly how did I get here?
And it wasn't well,
it was Hitler's fault and it was
[inaudible] fault.
Although it was definitely the fault of
both of them for social incident was
well,
it was also his fault because he was
playing the same game.
He just wasn't as good at it.
And of every living thing of all flesh,
two of every sort shall they'll bring
into the ark to keep them alive with
you.
They shall be male and female.
And so the they.
There's A.
There's another message in this story
which is that it isn't only Noah and his
family and human society that's
dependent on Noah's appropriate actions
in the world.
It's the entire living planet and in an
era of excessive and extreme and
genuinely disingenuous environmental
catastrophizing,
that's something to consider very
seriously.
Think perhaps there's nothing better
that you can do for everything.
All things considered,
including those things that are outside
the confines of human society than to
get your act together and align yourself
properly along all of the dimensions of
your being,
from,
from the tiniest microcosm to the to the
macrocosm,
and that's the way that all of being is
redeemed.
That's what the story suggests and we
read it.
You know,
a cynical modern people.
We read it as if it was written by
primitive people who thought that it was
really the case that someone could build
a boat and put two of every kind into it
and thereby save the world.
It's embarrassing to see things
interpreted in a manner that shallow,
especially by people who don't have
ignorance as a justification.
You know,
these stories have to appeal to
everyone,
right?
And there's lots of people in the world
who aren't very bright and so they tend
to take things concretely like a child
would take things concretely if you read
them a story,
and this story can be taken concretely,
but it has to be because the stories
have to be for everyone.
But if you're a sophisticated,
that doesn't mean that you should
dismiss it as if it's written for a
child.
It's maybe you have the obligation to
look a bit deeper and think for a moment
that it wouldn't be conserved for these
many thousands of years if there wasn't
something more to it than a casual
intellectual dismissal would indicate
and take the onto the of all food that
is eaten and thou shalt gather it to the
shelby food for the end for them.
Thus did noah.
According to all that God commanded him.
So did he.
And the Lord said unto Noah,
come down and all the house into the arc
for the I've seen righteous before me.
In this generation of every clean beast,
thou shalt take to the by sevens.
The male and female and obesity are
clean but not cleaned by to the male and
female and,
uh,
follows also of the error by sevens,
the male and the female to keep seed
alive upon the face of all the earth for
yet seven days,
I will cause it to rain upon the earth.
Forty days and 40 nights.
And every living substance that I have
made will I destroy from off the face of
the earth.
And Noah did according unto all that the
Lord commanded him.
And Noah was 600 years old when the
flood of waters was upon the earth.
And Noah went in and his sons and his
wife and his sons wives with them into
the arc because of the waters of the
flood,
of clean beasts and obese that are not
cleaning the fouls and have everything
that creepeth upon the earth.
They went in to and to and to know into
the arc.
The male and the female is guarded,
demanded Noah.
And it came to pass after seven days
that the waters of the flood were upon
the earth in the 600th year of Noah's
life.
In the second month,
the 17th day of the month,
the same day,
we're all the fountains of the great
deep broken up and the windows of Heaven
were opened and the rain was upon the
earth.
Forty days and 40 nights in the selfsame
day entered Noah and chairman,
Ham and Japheth,
sons of Noah and Noah,
his wife and the three wives of his sons
with him into the arc.
They in every beast after his kind and
all of the cattle after their kind and
every creeping thing that creepeth upon
the earth after his kind and every fowl
after his kind,
every bird of every sort of they went
into Noah unto no into the Ark,
to and to evolve flesh.
We're in is the breath of life
that makes no the ultimate shepherd,
right shepherd of all things tender of
the garden and shepherd of all things.
That's a hell of a role and maybe that's
the one that keeps you afloat during the
flood.
And they that went in,
went in,
male and female of all flesh is God had
commanded him.
And the Lord shout a man and the flood
was 40 days upon the earth and the
waters increased and bear up the ark and
it was lifted up above the earth and the
waters prevailed and were increased
greatly upon the earth.
15 cubits upward did the waters prevail
and the mountains were covered and all
flesh died that moved upon the earth.
Both have fallen of cattle and the beast
and over every creeping thing that
creepeth upon the earth and every man
and all in whose nostrils was the breath
of life of all that was in the dry land,
died in every living substance was
destroyed,
which was upon the face of the earth.
Both man and cattle and the creeping
things in the fall of the heaven.
And they were destroyed from the earth
and no only remained alive.
And they that were with him in the Ark.
And the water's prevailed upon the
earth.
One hundred and 50 days.
And God remembered no on every living
thing and all the capital that was with
him in the Ark.
And God made a wind to pass over the
earth and the waters receded the
fountains also of the deep and the
windows of heaven were stopped in.
The rain from heaven was restrained and
the water's returned from off the earth
continually.
And after the end of 150 days,
the waters were abated.
And the Ark rested in the seventh month,
on the Seventeenth Day of the month upon
the mountains of air rat.
And the water's decreased continually
until the 10th month,
the 10th month on the first day of the
month where the tops of the mountain
scene.
And it came to pass at the end of 40
days that Noah opened the window of the
Ark,
which he had made.
And he sent forth a raven which went to
and fro until the waters were dried up
from off the earth.
And he also sent forth a dove from him
to see if the waters were abated from
off the face of the ground.
But the dove found no rest for the sole
of her foot.
And she returned unto him in the Ark for
the waters on the face of the whole
earth that he put forth his hand and
took her and pulled her in unto him into
the Ark,
and he stayed yet another seven days.
And again,
he sent forth the dove out of the Ark.
And the devil came into him in the
evening and low in her mouth was an
olive leaf plucked off.
So no one knew that the waters were
abated from off the earth.
And he stayed there yet another seven
days and sent forth the dove,
which returned not again onto him any
more.
And it came to pass in the 600th and
first year in the first month.
The first day of the month of waters
were dried up from off the earth.
And Noah removed the covering of the
orchid,
looked up and behold,
the face of the ground was dry.
And in the second month on the seventh
and 20th day of the month was the dried.
And God spake unto Noah,
saying,
go forth of the arc,
thou and thy wife and they sons and
their sons waves with the
bring forth with the every living thing
that is with the of all flesh,
both of fall,
end of cattle and over every creeping
thing that creepeth upon the earth that
they may breed abundantly in the earth
and be fruitful and multiply upon the
earth.
And Noah went forth and his sons and his
wife and his sons wives with him.
Every beast creeping thing every fall
and whatsoever creepeth upon the earth
after their kinds went forth out of the
Ark.
And Noah building an altar unto the Lord
and took of every clean beast and of
every clean foul and offered burnt
offerings on the altar.
Immediate return to the sacrificial
motif.
And the Lord smelled a sweet savor.
And that's new as proper sacrifice.
And the Lord said into his heart,
I will not again curse the ground
anymore for man's sake.
For the imagination of Man's heart is
evil from his youth.
Neither will I again smite anymore.
Every living thing has I have done while
the Earth remaineth seed time and
harvest,
cold and heat in summer and winter,
day and night shall not cease,
and God blessed Noah and his sons and
said unto them,
be fruitful and multiply and replenish
the earth and the fear of you and the
dread of you shall be upon every beast
of the earth and upon every fowl of the
air upon all that moveth upon the earth,
upon all the fishes of the sea into your
hand or they delivered.
You know,
I've heard commentators,
David Suzuki,
for example,
who claim that the substructure of
Western culture in lines such as this
deliver the earth over to human beings
and and justify our ravaging of the,
of,
of being,
but I don't think that that's a very
careful reading and it seems to me that
given such matters,
given the importance of such matters
that are very close reading is actually
necessary.
You know,
in the story of Adam and Eve when Adam
and eve are thrown out of the garden,
God tells eve that she's going to be
subordinated to her husband.
He doesn't say that.
That's what should happen.
He says that's what's going to happen,
and the same thing as far as I'm
concerned is contained in lines like
this isn't necessarily that this is
something that should happen.
It's something that did happen.
It's quite remarkable.
You know,
to think about how long ago these lions
were penned,
it wasn't obvious until perhaps the 19
sixties that we had dominated the earth
so completely that it's very
future existence was in our hands and
that's a prophetic element of this tale
and the fear of you and the dread of you
shall be upon every beast of the earth
and upon every fowl of the air and upon
all that moveth upon the earth and upon
all the fishes of the sea into your
hand.
Are they delivered?
It's like,
that's exactly right.
Every moving thing that lives shall be
meat for you.
Even as the green herb I've given you
all things,
have I given you all things but flesh
with the life therapy,
which is the blood thereof,
shall you not eat and surely your blood
of your lives will I require at the hand
of every beast will I required in at the
hand of man at the hand of every man's
brother will I require the life of man?
This is a hard section to interpret,
but what it means is something like
this.
God describes the dominion over the
planet that revivified humanity will
have and notes the power that goes along
with that and then puts a limitation on
it and the limitation is maintain the
sanctity of life despite your power.
And although it's not easy to extract
from the manner in which this has been
translated.
What God is telling Noah is that if you
kill yourself,
if you kill someone else,
and if any animal kills a human being,
that there will be a price to pay for
that.
So there's a an opportunity which is
that the descendants of Noah can
dominate the earth,
but there's a moral limitation placed on
that.
Which is nonetheless,
life itself is to be regarded as
sanctified and sacred.
Whoever shared with man's blood,
by man shall his blood be shed for in
the image of God made he man and you be
fruitful and multiply.
Bring forth abundantly in the earth and
multiply their in and God spake to Noah
and to his sons with him saying,
and I behold I establish my covenant
with you and with your seat after you
and with every living creature that is
with you.
Have the fall in the cattle and to every
beast of earth that is with you.
For all that.
Go out of the Ark to every beast of the
earth.
And I will establish my covenant with
you.
Neither shall all flesh be cut off
anymore by the waters of the flood.
Neither shall there be any more.
A flood to destroy the earth.
And God said,
this is the token of the covenant which
I make between me and you and every
living creature that is with you for
perpetual generations.
I do set my bow in the cloud and it
shall be for a token of a covenant
between me and the Earth and it shall
come to pass when I bring a cloud over
the earth that the Hoa shall be seen in
the cloud and I will remember my
covenant which is between me and you and
every living creature of all flesh and
the waters shall no more become a flood
to destroy all flesh.
There's a negotiated agreement there of
sorts
and then negotiated agreement is as far
as I can tell to the degree that
humanity agrees to act in the manner of
Noah.
Then the threat of catastrophic
destruction will remain at bay and the
bowl shall be in the cloud and I will
look upon it that I may remember the
everlasting covenant between God and
every living creature of all flesh that
is upon the earth.
And God said unto Noah,
this is the token of the covenant which
I've established between me and all
flesh that is upon the earth.
This is the token of the covenant which
I have established between me and all
flesh.
That is upon the earth,
so that's a good place to stop and
there's no lecture next week by the way,
because the theater was booked so
there'll be a one week break and then
when we get back we'll finish the story
of Noah.
There's not much left of it.
We'll talk about the tower of Babel,
which is a very short story,
but a very,
very interesting one.
And then we'll move on to the story of
Abraham and so thank you very much for
coming in.
We'll see you again
two weeks.
Thank you.
Now is the person who has the
notification for the meetup after this
here and do they have the notification?
Okay.
Because if you give that to me this
time,
I'll remember to read it before everyone
leaves.
So do you want to start?
Okay.
So see,
let's see if the mic is working because
lots of people will listen to this
question and so.
Okay.
So you said on a recent live stream that
you were two,
you didn't have enough energy to answer
this question,
but you said it was intriguing.
So I was wondering if you had the energy
to answer how someone might help someone
that has borderline personality disorder
by example,
by example.
You have an example?
No,
no,
I don't.
I don't mean that precisely.
I mean that the.
Let's not take borderline personality
disorder precisely as the example.
Okay.
I understand the question.
The question to some degree is how do
you help someone that's lost and the
answer to that is if they aren't willing
to not be lost,
you cannot help them.
And I would also say that as a clinician
you see,
I mean it's an.
It's a statement that's informed,
I would say by my mythological
knowledge,
but also by straight clinical wisdom,
not mine particularly.
I mean one of the things that Carl
Rogers pointed out was that there were
necessary preconditions for entering
into a therapeutic relationship and that
that would be really any relationship
where the mutual flourishing of the two
people involved was the paramount goal.
And one of the preconditions was that
both people have to want that to happen
and Rogers believed he didn't know how
to get the horse to drink.
Once you had brought it to the water,
and I've thought about that a lot
because when people are really lost,
sometimes they're so lost that they
can't be found and I think the only
thing that you can do in a situation
like that is get your life together and
she and manifest the reality of an
alternative motive being that's what
you've got.
And so that's the only way I knew of to
solve an intractable problem and I would
say the reason that I went down that
direction with regards to borderline
personality disorders because it's one
of the most serious of the personality
disorder.
It's very difficult to treat and so I'll
generalize from that to situations that
are very difficult to deal with.
And you know,
there's a statement too,
and this has nothing to do with
borderline personality disorder per se.
There's a statement in the new testament
that's really vicious.
In fact,
there's a number of them,
but this is a particularly vicious one
and that is don't cast pearls before
swine.
And what that means is if you're trying
to help and it doesn't work,
then stop helping.
It's not helping,
right?
It may be just wasting your time.
It might be making things worse.
Now,
if you're.
If you're offering something and it's
not taken,
then perhaps you should be offering it
somewhere else and sometimes if you
offer hand in,
the person won't take it.
You have to stop offering the hand and
then what you do is you go off and you
have your life and sometimes that means
in people's lives,
for example,
that they have to leave their family
members behind.
There's a scene in the new testament.
This is another very hard scene where
Christ is walking down the road with his
disciples.
I hope I've got this story right,
but I've got it essentially right,
and his mother calls to him and says,
I believe that he's supposed to come
back to the home because his uncle has
died and that there's going to be a
funeral,
and he turns to his mother and says
something like,
let the dead bury their dead.
I'm about my father's business.
It's something like that.
And you read that and you think,
Huh,
that should have been edited out.
No,
but it shouldn't have been edited out
because it's exactly right because
sometimes the thing you do is walk away
because there's no other solution and if
you
are trapped in pathological
relationships and you see no way out of
them,
if you,
if someone who is sinking has their
hands around your neck and is pulling
you down,
you're not obligated to drown with them.
No.
There's a rule to.
If you're a lifeguard,
you know,
some of you have had lifeguard training.
How do you approach someone who's
drowning and panicking in the water feed
out?
Right?
Like this.
It's like all save you,
but that doesn't mean you get to drown
me while I'm doing it and if it's you
drown or both of us drown.
It's you drown.
And that's wisdom.
That's not cruelty,
right?
So yeah,
couple of questions about dialogue and
engaging in dialogue with people.
So the first issue that I face is I have
a very high need for intellectual
stimulation and I don't get that with
most people.
It's something like,
um,
you can,
you can have a dialogue for a time,
but then it
titrate openness.
Yeah.
And and now,
but then they started run out of ideas
or they can keep up and it sort of falls
apart and okay,
this is a problem that intellectuals
have quite frequently.
You said they,
they sort of,
once they start reading difficult to
devoting stuff,
they stopped wanting to talk to regular
people and I think that contributes to
the disconnect that you see between
intellectuals and working class people
and,
and stuff like that.
And the other question I had was about,
okay wait,
I don't know if that's the question.
I mean I believe there's a question in
there,
but I,
the question is how,
how do you,
how should we address that?
How should I address it?
And is that something that can be
dressed?
Well,
part of,
part of the answer to that is that's
what the universities were for.
I mean,
you know,
not everybody is equipped to or
interested in engaging in high level
discussion of abstract and creative
ideas.
You know,
you hear this idea that everyone's
creative.
That's a lie.
It's a straightforward.
Is that true?
Creativity is very,
very rare.
And so,
and if you happen to be a creative
person or if you happen to be someone
who's profoundly interested in ideas,
you are in a pronounced minority,
just as you are,
if you happen to be extremely
extroverted or extremely agreeable,
are extremely conscientious.
These are minority issues.
And what you do is you find likeminded
people who are capable of engaging that
we know a heavyweight heavyweight
weightlifters compete with heavy weight
weight lifters for a reason and everyone
thinks that's fine.
And the same thing applies to
intellectual and creative endeavors.
So what you do is you try to find a
community where that's,
that's the nature of the community and
you likely have to find a relationship
like that as well.
You know?
So I don't think so.
I think what contributes to the siloing
is the arrogance goes along with it
because if you're,
you can be interested in ideas and you
can be creative.
Well that's the arrogance of the
intellect,
right?
That's the thing the Catholic Church had
warned about for centuries is the
arrogance of the intellect.
So because if you're,
if you're wise as well as smart and
there is no relationship between being
smart and being wise,
they are not the same thing.
There's no quick pathway from smart to
wise.
And many of the people who I've known
who were very wise were,
some of them were intellectually
impaired and we're still wise.
So it's the arrogance that brings up the
block.
And I see this for example happening in
the United States in particular because
the last time I went down there for
example,
I was.
I had friends down there and some of
those friends are very,
very smart people and some of them were
talking about the trump voters and they
were talking about the trump voters with
contempt and I thought you better watch
that because that's 50 percent of the
population and it might be convenient to
think that they're stupid and beneath
you,
but it's not conducive to a civil state.
And there's no evidence that it's true
because there isn't a straight line
between intelligent and wise.
And so I think that if your.
If your character is developed and
you're intelligent,
you can have your siloed,
creative community,
but you develop enough wisdom so that
you can see all the things that people
can do that or have high ethical utility
that are outside the intellectual
domain.
You know,
and I think that's why in the New
Testament,
I think that's why Christ is a
carpenter,
right?
Because,
well,
first of all,
carpenter is one of those jobs that when
you're dishonest,
it manifests itself immediately because
what you build falls down and so if
you're an honest carpenter,
you build a good house.
So there's a nice metaphor there,
but it's also.
It's also a warning in some sense,
against the the equation of intellectual
brilliance with moral superiority.
And so if the intellects would drop
their moral superiority and fat chance
there is of that,
then that divide between the working
class say and the elite would would
resolve.
And there's every reason to have respect
for decent working class people.
It's on their labor as the left wingers
at least hypothetically agree that the
entire edifice of the culture is,
is resting.
So you can have your cake and eat it
too,
but you have to not assume that your
niche makes you superior.
And it's very difficult for smart
people,
especially smart.
There's this scene in niches.
Sins thus spake Zarathustra Zarathustra.
The prophet comes down from the mountain
and he comes into a public square and
there's this crowd around this little
midget who was only about this high,
who has a gigantic ear and everyone is
marveling at him.
Well,
that's what the moderate intellect is
like.
It's a midget with a giant.
Well mouth generally not an ear and the
being is underdeveloped,
but the intellect is hyper activated and
it makes the person extraordinarily
unbalanced.
And it's partly because a,
they can't compete outside the
intellectual realm and that makes them
very bitter because they tend to think,
well God,
I'm so smart.
Everything should just come to me.
It's like,
sorry,
that's not how the world works.
And,
and it,
it also that,
that,
and that,
that attitude is immediately evident to
people that they're talking to when they
talk in the manner that they talk.
If they are arrogant intellectuals of
that sort.
You see that in the simpsons did a good
job of that with Comic Book Guy.
I mean he completely useless in every
possible dimension with an Iq of about
160 and it's very annoying to people who
have an Iq of 160 that they can also be
completely useless,
but it happens a lot.
So yeah.
Thank you.
Long time.
No,
see how are you doing?
Thanks.
So I was at first going to ask about
your thoughts on a very popular TV show.
Rick and Morty
just recommended that to me and they
said they thought I would find it funny
and that makes me nervous because I like
the simpsons and I liked the trailer
park boys for actually liked the Turner.
I really liked the trailer park boys.
And so if someone said,
I know it's so sad,
you know,
but they said that I would like rick and
Morty,
so I'm kind of afraid to even watch it.
It does have a nihilistic theme to it,
I would say.
So that was just quite telling of the
young population which say falling in
love with it.
Everyone's talking about it,
so,
okay,
well I'll definitely watch it because
I'd been looking for something to watch
when I'm brain dead at night.
So,
but I just had to tell him my question
from a different angle if I,
if I may.
Um,
and it's about,
um,
the case that governments,
let's say,
such as Russia and Iran,
they are even more extreme cases like
isis.
They do not want to conform to a
nihilistic aspects of the West.
And as a result,
they've taken an anti western approach
as someone with a Middle Eastern
background.
Um,
I've been trying to figure out where the
origins of this hostility more precisely
comes from and why things are the way
they are.
I recently found out that certain key
uranium philosophers and political
activist who are partially
intellectually responsible for the 19,
79 and renowned revolution were highly
influenced by the anti western
Heideggerian philosophy.
And this is partially why they believe
that an Islamic state,
uh,
would it be be unnecessary counter
position,
uh,
to the,
to the nihilistic western thought.
Uh,
you,
I know you also found there with
Aleksandr Dugin,
a puddings advisor,
except Dougan doesn't really seem to
have a coherent answer.
He says that an answer like that is
necessary and that hypothetically it's
something that Russia might be able to
offer,
but the details seem to me somewhat
obscure.
I mean the Russians may be,
the Russians are doing what Solzhenitsyn
suggested in returning to Orthodox
Christianity,
although Russia's corrupt enough so that
it's very difficult to tell from the
outside if that's mirror collusion
between a corrupt church and a corrupt
state or if there's something genuine
going on there.
Now,
you know,
the,
I would say there's a question under
your question which is tyranny or
nihilism?
Well,
that's a good question man.
That's a good question.
Well,
lots of people would pick tyranny over
nihilism.
And so if that's the only choice that
people are offered then.
And I also think that tyranny is
stronger than nihilism because what are
you going to do?
Organize nihilists hardly.
Well,
look at,
look at what happened to,
what was that thing in central park,
you know,
against the one percent.
Jesus.
I mean,
what a dismal affair that was.
We'd like things to be different.
How well we don't know.
It's like
thank you.
So you know your.
You can just run over that if you're a
tyrannical and organized,
you can just run over that like there's
nothing there at all and that I think
there is a danger and I do think that
were enticing Islamofascism let's say by
our nihilistic weakness and I think more
than that,
I think that we're doing something more
than that because one of the things that
I've been curious about,
and I'm going way out on limb here,
is I've been really interested in the
alliance between the Neo Marxist
denialists suspicious or the Neo
Marxist,
postmodern,
especially the feminists and the
Islamofascism.
I just don't get that.
It's like there's something very,
very interesting going on there and I
think part of it is that when you,
when you drift too far into the
nihilistic substructure,
there is a huge call for tyrannical
order that manifests itself
unconsciously.
And so that's the dynamic that I see
playing out in that peculiar
relationship between the modern neo
Marxist feminists in the Islamic
fascists.
I don't.
I don't know.
That's a very.
That's very interesting that that's a
very interesting idea that you brought
to mind.
I had no idea that there was a
relationship between heidegger and what
happened in Iran in the 19 seventies.
If you could send me a citation about
that or something to read,
I'd be very interested in doing that.
So.
Okay.
Yep.
Thanks.
Thank you.
That's,
that's the closest thing
I think I'll experience to,
to Arnold Schwartzenegger actually
delivering that line.
April titled the Case for Free Speech
Distribution.
Yeah.
Not Ross,
but yeah.
Whereby I guess the square root of the
number of people involved in some sort
of productive endeavor
do half the work
would result in half the production.
Oh,
it's a nasty,
nasty law.
Yeah.
It was also known as price's law.
Four hundred,
500 people we've all cleaned up.
Great.
What you're saying is that if you say
that this Perrino distribution
approximates a natural law,
we all understand the force of gravity
and there's no escaping the influence of
gravity,
that means that there's 20 people in
this room who are going to be,
I guess candidates to accomplishing.
I guess the goal of being the next
Jordan Peterson.
Hopefully there's fewer of them.
Two things.
The first is if it isn't obvious what
the population would be,
that you would compare this population
too,
right?
Because you could say,
well,
the boundaries,
the 400 people in this room,
but it isn't necessarily the case.
The 400 people in this room might be the
square root of the broader population.
We're interested in this sort of thing.
But with the prieto distribution,
what you also see is that it's itself
similar.
And so,
um,
let's say there's 400 people doing
something,
20 of them are doing half the work,
but if you take 20,
those 24 of them are doing half the work
of the 20 and one of the forest doing
half the work of the four.
And so
it,
it.
So why am I telling you that it's it,
isn't it?
Well,
first of all,
it isn't that there isn't useful work to
be done at multiple slices of the prieto
distribution.
But the other thing is it's also the
case that there's not only one prieto
distribution,
right?
Because he might say,
well,
if it's just the square root of the
number of people in a domain that are
doing half the work,
then what do you do with the rest of the
people?
And the answer to that might be while
they're in a pre to a different prieto
distribution as well,
where they're doing something
productive.
So.
Well,
I think it's a good question.
Like,
ah,
we don't exactly.
Um,
so,
so the basic rule is the look,
the basic rule is example,
if you take 100 scientists in a given
domain,
10 of them will have published half the
papers.
And this works with everything.
It works with every creative domain.
The rule applies.
So now the question is why?
And I think the answer to that seems to
be,
and I've watched people who've become
spectacularly successful and what
happens is that zero is a really bad
place to be,
right?
It's really hard to get out of zero.
And that's often why people are trapped
in poverty because if you have nothing
getting to something is virtually
impossible.
Once you have something,
getting to a little more of something is
actually quite a bit easier.
And so what seems to happen,
this is also called the matthew
principle,
right?
It's the same principle.
So that's a new testament citation.
Let's say the matthew principle is to
those who have everything more will be
given from those who have nothing.
Everything will be taken.
That's another one of those lines in the
new testament that you'd think that a
good editor would have just got rid of.
So but,
but,
but I think what it is is that every
time you make a step forward,
the probability that you'll be able to
take the next step forward increases.
And it seems to increase in a nonlinear
way.
So the,
the world that the matthew principal
describes is nonlinear.
You know,
so you might say,
well,
what's your trajectory if you're moving
upward?
Well,
it's not this,
it's this.
What's your trajectory if you're moving
downward,
it's not this,
it's this,
right?
You Fall,
you fall,
you plummet,
you rise,
you transcend.
It's something like that and you might
say,
well that's a hell of a world,
but whatever.
It has to be run by some principle and
the principle that it appears to be run
by.
Yes,
no,
no.
It doesn't mean that at all.
What it means is that every truth claim
you make,
including those that are implicit in
your actions,
carries with it an ethic that justifies
or doesn't justify the action.
So for example,
let's say I have a tool and I say it's
an ax and I go out in the forest and I
cut down.
I tried to cut down a tree with it and
it doesn't work.
It's not an ax,
it's something else.
And so what the,
what the.
There's a good book on pragmatism called
the metaphysical club,
a history of American ideas.
It's one I would really recommend and
what the pragmatists.
I can't give you a full answer because
this is such a complicated issue,
but what the pragmatist we're wrestling
with back in the late 18 hundreds,
the late 18 hundreds.
This was William James and his crew in,
in in Boston.
I'm including a philosopher named CS
purse,
who is perhaps America's greatest
philosopher.
They were wrestling with the same issue
that the postmodernist would wrestle
with 100 years later,
which is
things are indefinitely complex and
we're not very bright.
So how is it that we can make claims to
truth about anything and what they were,
what their hypothesis essentially was,
is that with every action and with every
truth claim you similar demarcate a
territory within which that claim is
valid and you,
you determine whether the claim is valid
by noting whether your prediction about
the outcome of your action or your or
your belief is commensurate is in
keeping with so if the outcome is in
keeping with the prediction than what
you've said or done is true or good
enough and that's as good as you get.
And so that's the pragmatic perspective.
And then when,
when,
when the pragmatists encountered Charles
Dark Charles Darwin's works works,
they immediately recognized that Darwin
had generated a pragmatic solution to
the problem of the impossibility of
being.
The impossibility of being is this,
there's way more cosmos than there is
you.
You are going to die.
You cannot generate a sufficient
solution to the problem of you're being.
No one can.
Nothing.
Cat,
it's like the environment is a snake
that moves unpredictably across time and
you're trying to stay on its back while
I was how to,
how does the Darwinian process deal with
that?
It produces infinite variance roughly
speaking,
almost all of which die.
And that's how it solves the problem
across time and the things that exist.
This,
the things that stay alive,
our true enough,
and that's the best you get.
That's the argument I was trying to have
with Sam Harris because Harris doesn't
take his evolutionary cycle,
his evolutionary theory,
seriously enough,
but we get.
We kept getting bogged down.
Anyways,
that's,
that's the best answer to that.
I'd like to agree with that,
but it's not true.
Yup,
Yup.
True scientific.
You really do like to ask hard
questions,
don't you?
Um,
I think it depends.
See,
this is also why like the Piagetian take
let's say on,
on pragmatism,
because I think that pragmatism as a
philosophy has the limitation that you
just described,
but only if you think about the Games is
limited.
If you have to play the game in an
iterative way,
then that issue resolves itself and the
game theorists have done a good job of
mapping that out.
It's like you could say,
let's say pragmatically speaking,
there is no reason I shouldn't deceive
you once.
If I can get what I want,
it's yeah.
Yeah.
Except that I'm probably not only going
to interact with you once.
I'm going to interact with you a lot and
even if it isn't you that I interact
with,
it's going to be a bunch of beings that
are so much you that it might as well
be.
You might as well be you.
It's going to be me if nothing else.
And so the pragmatic game stretched
across time would include the necessity
of interability in relationship to the
validations of the truth claims.
That's,
that's how it looks to me when you.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna.
Stop you say that again?
Denied on several occasions.
Yes.
Like you're good at rhetoric.
Thank you.
Yes.
But that's not all I am.
Uh,
so this is on behalf of somebody,
uh,
Dr Peterson having listened to your
expositions on the mythological
evolution and amalgamation of religion
and keeping in mind your working
definitions of belief and truth and
despite the obvious reasons for somebody
of your background to identify most with
Christianity,
my understanding is that you believe
Christianity to be the most complete and
articulated form of many of the
metaphysical ideas that proceeded.
It led up to that.
Keeping that in mind,
would it also be accurate to therefore
say that you're not only a believer in
Christianity,
but also if to a lesser degree also
believer in,
in Marta,
in the ancient Egyptian gods and the
subsequent gods that you've spoken of
here,
uh,
that lead up and contributed to the form
of Christianity that you're discussing
and that you identify with.
Okay.
I got to take that one apart a little
bit.
I'm bounded in my judgment with regards
to Christianity by my ignorance.
I'm no student of Hinduism so I can't
make the claim forthrightly that there's
something intrinsically superior to the
Judeo Christian tradition because I
don't know enough to make that claim.
The claim I can make is that there's
something that's dreadfully right about
this core elements of the Judeo
Christian tradition and I've seen
analogs to that.
Like one of the things I'd like to do,
for example,
is to do a a short series on the Tao Te
Ching because that is one remarkable
document.
Once you know,
especially you might want to read it,
you can go online and read.
It's very short.
Tao Te Ching t a o,
t h I C H I n g,
and it's the fundamental texts of Taoism
and once you know that the world of
being is made of chaos and order and you
know that that's represented by the Yin
and the Yang,
all of a sudden you can understand the
Tao te Ching and it's just.
It's brilliantly simple and
straightforward in new sex position,
but it also seems to me to be entirely
commensurate with the line of,
of let's call it logic.
It's more like a,
the the mode of description of being
that's encapsulated in these stories.
Now with regards to being a believer,
people ask me all the time,
two thinks,
hey,
do you believe in God and are you a
Christian?
And they answered without both of those
is actually.
There's two answers.
One is what the hell makes you think
it's any of your business?
That's the first answer.
And the second is why do you think that
you mean the same thing with those
questions that I would mean with my
answer.
So you know,
because it's,
it's such a funny thing because I've
spent like three.
This is no accusation with regards to
your questions in the least.
You know,
I think it's more about trying to track
the development of these ideas and you
know,
the residual truths and psych,
psychological significance of all these
other traditions that team.
Well,
you know,
the,
the.
I've been floored by either mythological
structures like when I first understood
or thought I understood the meaning of
the Mesopotamian creation method,
just I've never recovered from that I
would say,
and the same thing is true of the
investigations I did into the Egyptian
myths of Horus and Isis and Osiris and
seth.
It's just they,
they're so relevant.
I mean there are so unbelievably
relevant.
And how do,
how do see this is a problem that none
of us really know how to,
how to solve.
It's like there are sources of wisdom
all over the world,
let's say,
and they need to be made commensurate
with one another,
which isn't to say that they need to be
turned into a fast food.
A mall,
you know,
that's,
that's like multiculturalism,
right?
It's like all the food of the world
served in the most terrible possible
manner all in one place and something
like that.
And you don't want to do that with
comparative religion.
It's just water everything down and say,
well,
it's all nice.
It's like,
no,
it is not nice.
Yeah.
Or that it's all the same because it's
not all the same.
So the job of communicating between
those domains of wisdom is really
continuing.
Right?
It's been a problem ever since the
beginning of civilization,
but it's continuing and I would say the
psychoanalysts too young in particular
was a huge,
huge steps in the direction of doing
that in an extraordinarily positive way
and not a simple minded way at all and
not just hand waving that.
Oh well it's.
Everyone has one in all shall have
prizes.
Not that.
So yeah,
thank you.
Last question
actually is a kind of in the same vein,
but it's in regards to another kind of
mythology.
So in terms of I guess Carl Jung's own
those,
sorry to mix.
Certainly tall,
but a lot of the.
I actually found some kind of archetypes
like for example,
in my own life,
but also I've noticed in European life.
So for example,
in regards to Odin and norse mythology
with Carl Jung's essay,
I've only been able to touch you skim it
because I've been trying to find
something like.
Because it felt like there's always this
kind of psyche that was almost
underneath,
I guess,
Western civilization and we've seen it
really like embodied in this specific
figure,
this deity,
the wanderer,
the knowledge,
gather the seeker,
but he's also a war.
God is,
he is all these different aspects that
are an accumulation of what seems to be
something that's distinctly western.
And I feel this is almost like the
symbol in a way.
Of course,
it's not always positive.
There seems to be something.
Maybe there seems to be something.
I do think that the idea of the
individual has been articulated most
fully in the west.
I don't think that's really a,
I don't think that's a contentious claim
actually.
Um,
that doesn't mean that the latent
structures from which that idea might
emerge weren't also many other places
simultaneously.
And the other thing from let's say from
a biological perspective is that we're
only talking about differences of a few
hundred years in terms of the
manifestation of these ideas.
Right?
From A,
from an evolutionary perspective,
that's,
it's instantaneous.
And it's like,
well,
a new idea has to arise somewhere.
So it's going to be somewhere first and
but it,
it's spreading.
Christianity for example,
spreads so rapidly that it's absolutely
beyond belief and it is actually
spreading more rapidly in China now than
it did in ancient Rome.
So.
Well in regards to that,
it's also been seen like almost in the
wake of a dying Christianity.
I've noticed that like there's been a
tendency to go towards I guess paganism,
right?
Yes.
I'm understand the lake.
Some people love at off.
Yes,
you have waco,
which was mainly a manifestation of all
Alistair Crowley has it works which were
then handed off to whoever actually made
the actual ideology.
And then next thing you know,
we're finding something almost more
stable in I guess norse mythology and it
seems like it's acting almost as a
pendulum swing from something that.
Well,
people are like.
The thing is,
is when,
when,
when one mythological structure
collapses,
it's going to collapse into another
mythological structure or another set of
mythological structures and,
and because you,
you can't get out of the mythological
structures,
there's no possible way of doing that.
What?
And so I wouldn't say necessarily that
the fact that other belief systems
emerge in the aftermath of the collapse
of the overarching belief system,
I don't think that that's necessarily a
bad idea.
I think that it has its attendant
dangers.
And so I should stop because I'm
starting to get tired and I'm not going
to be able to formulate any clear
answers than that.
And it's also 10:00.
So we also do have to start.
Oh yes.
There is an unofficial meetup and
discussion group at Hemingway's
restaurant.
Second floor,
142 cumberland street.
Just say you're with the Jordan Peterson
discussion group.
Yes.
Everyone is invited.
If you say you're with the Jordan
Peterson discussion group,
please don't miss.
Behave too badly.